presenters at 11 30 you have Department
of Information Technology coming in
their their role or charge is twofold
today with you
first they're going to come in and talk
to you about
um for those capital projects that are
I.T related
the department of Information Technology
is involved with those that's often a
question this committee has when there
are projects included in the capital
budget you know if there's been some
review of the need and some process to
determine you know it's just the
appropriate project to move forward
and then the second is at one o'clock
you have the department of
administrative Services coming in the
department of administrative Services is
responsible for the majority of the
state buildings that you see around
um here in Concord up at hospital
grounds Hazen drive this uh State House
Annex buildings
um so they'll be talking to you about
what they do in terms of managing those
buildings but also the the director of
Public Works will be here and he'll talk
to you about what they do in terms of
looking at the state agency's request
for capital projects and how they go
about basically creating this blue book
from this big binder so I just wanted to
point that out before I got started with
my actual presentation
so if you can go to the orientation
document
this is meant to be just a um a One-Stop
shop for the committee members to find
different elements of the capital budget
things such as the statutes ways that we
track projects
requests that were made and so I think
the most important page is that flip the
cover page and it's the contact
information
so if you have any questions
or you need additional information about
anything that we're looking at in terms
of the capital budget please feel free
to reach out to me you can call me send
me an email and and I will get back to
you
there's a website there so all the
documents that you're going to see in
front of this committee except for this
binder and this blue book will be
available electronically
and it's you can find it at that web web
link right there
hmm as I go along if anybody has
questions just stop me I'm not going to
go every single page of this document we
will skip through it
so the pages one through five are just
the statutes related to the capital
budget and why
um you have a house bill 25 essentially
so I won't go through that with you but
really on page six just to kind of give
you an overview of the capital budget
process this is a process that starts
back in March April time frame the
agencies start considering what capital
projects they'd like to pursue
and by May 1st they need to provide
Department of administrative services
with their request for capital projects
that's what this large binder is it's
all their requests
by June 30th
of last year the governor had to have
hearings on the capital budget
so this process has already started so
so there's some some of these pieces of
information may be a little dated
so from the governor's capital budget
hearings certain projects are chosen by
the governor and his team to further
investigate or review to determine what
it might cost to move it forward
that becomes this Blue Book
so again it takes everything that's in
this big binder
that the agencies have submitted and
then the governor and his team along
with Public Works will pick a number of
projects that they want to investigate a
little bit further in terms of the cost
and the need and then they produce this
book by December
and this comes out
then the governor by February 15th
proposes his operating budget and his
capital budget so you saw that a couple
weeks ago and everybody got the blue
book excuse me the green book
um where that the governor is
recommending what he would like to see
for capital projects
um
by the time the legislature is done
doesn't mean the committee has to agree
with them it just gives you a starting
point you're going to hear from agencies
that are going to tell you that there's
a projects they may not have been
included by the governor that they'd
like to see
um there may be projects that are
included that agencies come in and say
never mind we don't want to do that one
for some reason or another
so this process over the next couple of
weeks you'll be hearing a lot from the
agencies
once you get done with the capital
budget
it'll cross over to the Senate the
Senate will go through a similar process
and they'll add and delete make changes
as they feel that they would like and
once they're done they'll pass it and
they'll come back over to the house and
the house will decide whether you want
to take it to a committee a conference
or not
if you decide you want to do a committee
a conference then you would let the
Senate know the Senate would concur or
not Concur and at that point the chair
of the house committee because it's a
house bill would then be responsible for
setting up the committee conference and
the meeting dates and times and running
that meeting
once there's agreement
hopefully there's agreement
the committee a conference report would
come back to the full legislature we
would get a thumbs up or thumbs down
vote assuming it gets a thumbs up vote
it would go to the governor for
signature for non-signature or for a
veto
um I think one of the
challenges for the chair of uh of Public
Works is to try to get
um the capital budget out
with just a Voice vote without minimal
debate if any
um and I think over the last few years
you've seen that and that's because the
committee works pretty well with each
other to determine what the I think I'll
use Representative mcconkey's term
critical needs are for the state
so that's that's essentially the process
you'll go through
if you look on pages seven and eight
that's just the docket for House Bill 25
just to kind of show you the dates of
when things are occurring and what's
happening
if you go to page
it's going to be a spreadsheet look
it's going to have a through columns a
through F you'll see Governor house
senate and then there'll be a difference
column between the Senate and the house
so during this process
I will be tracking all your decisions
and keeping a document similar to this
that would just have the governor and
house columns in a difference column and
providing that to the committee members
as you're starting to make decisions
just to help you keep track of where
you're at with the capital budget but
everything this is the capital budget
from 21 so every project that was listed
is found under column A and then changes
that were done
things that were Deleted things that
were added throughout the process
and then the total numbers
and then when you get if you flip to
page 15
you're going to see rows 218 through 223
that provides you with the capital
Appropriations that are being allowed
through the capital budget
and you can see on row 220
um
the the capital appropriation that was
going to be generally funded bonds is
about 127.5 million dollars
Highway funds was just under 16 million
dollars and then other funds
was 16.3 million dollars other funds
would be things like The Liquor
Commission the Lottery Commission
fishing game
or if an agency has uh
a dedicated fund that they're going to
use towards a capital project or part of
a capital project you would see that as
other funds
you don't have to worry too too much
about that because I'll help keep you
straight on that
um
as part of this package I've also
included the capital budget from 2021
so this would be the 22 20
1 excuse me 22 23 Capital Appropriations
so you'll have that if you want to flip
through that as you're going through
this
uh
this Cycles a recommendation for
projects you can see what was a approved
last cycle
you're going to see it when you look at
the capital budget looking you know it's
just on pages 17 through
22 it's basically a listing of all the
projects
and amounts and then sources of funds
are included there once you move off
into page 23
you're going to see a lot of narrative
some of this narrative is just what we
would call can language you know if the
university system is getting some money
there's some can language that's
included
um
about their Appropriations
you'll also see if there's um
a request to amend a prior capital
budget
if you would if you were to approve that
we would include it as a section in
house bill 25.
um
just trying to find one real quick that
yeah there's not one in not one right
here
the other thing that you do in this
section is that
we'll go through the what we call the
lapse extension so agencies will request
as part of the capital budget to extend
the Appropriations from prior Capital
budgets
um typically this committee has a
subcommittee that will look at all the
lapse extensions and if for those
projects that aren't extended we'll see
if there's any balances left in those
Appropriations that could possibly be
repurposed for projects that you might
be interested in funding
um
I think the one cautionary note is in
Prior years you have seen this
repurposing
um be for you know million plus dollars
that could be used I think we've gone
through and grabbed the low hanging
fruit so to speak as well as with covid
and then the slow uptick once covid was
kind of going away and projects started
to move again getting supplies and
materials and people to do projects um
some of these Capital Appropriations
haven't been spent so you're not going
to be closing out as many projects as
you have in the past so that may impact
your ability to find these additional
funds to repurpose
I talk about the lapse extensions if you
go to
um
page 28 that starts it's it's
Row three and that goes to the end of
the capital budget and the last capital
budget there were
185 lapse extensions requested
so basically there was 185 projects on
the books
they all come from a variety of years
many for are for the more recent Capital
budgets but there are some that are
older out there
um that agencies have requested to
continue to have the ability to use
those Appropriations
um and as I mentioned there will be a
subcommittee that will look at that in
this group
we'll have agencies come in I'll be
working with agencies that only have a
couple that get memos or letters from
them to confirm why they need the lapse
extension
we'll also make sure if an agency
um failed to get a lapse extension put
into the capital budget that they let
this committee know so they can be added
so that they don't lose the ability to
spend the money that they're trying to
use for a project
if you skip ahead to page 40
.
what you have there is the summary of
the all the requests that were made as
part of this big notebook
by agency and then if you flip 41
through the end that's by each agency
you can see each project that they were
requesting
and how much they thought it would cost
at the time they made this request so
again these were the requests that were
made back in June to the governor
this binder will be in represent
mcconkey's office he'll have this
available if people would like to look
at it or need to look at it
agencies when they come before you have
been instructed to use the governor's
capital budget recommended capital
budget when they present to you
so that should be the base
um focus for for any of the
presentations and from that the agencies
will raise questions
um or make requests of the committee for
things that they didn't have included or
if they need changes uh to whatever
Appropriations that were included
any questions so far
representative Melvin yes on uh you've
got General Federal and Highway I
understand what temperature is what is
above so other funds would be
um
funds that are dedicated for a certain
purpose such as sweepstakes or lottery
or liquor
funds would be considered other funds in
this document dedicated funds that are
go to a specific agency so if there's a
uh
just trying to think of a dedicated fund
off the
um police standards and training fund if
they were to use that for a capital
project
that would be the other funds so it
when the agency comes in they would
identify what that fund was that they
were using you typically
um the major ones you're going to see
are if liquor or Lottery come in
um fishing game
because they have some dedicated funds
or have a dedicated fund which is Fish
and Game fund but they also have other
funds that they can sometimes access
those are the typical ones you'll see
you're welcome
anyone else at this time
thank you
so if if you could just grab the um
Governor's capital budget and I'll just
kind of walk you through that just to
help orientate you on that document
you flip to page one it's going to be
the summary
and you're going to see it you know it's
an alphabetical order
starts with administrative services and
ends with the veterans home
it gives you a total funds and then by
fund types and
under section one there's 173 million
dollars total funds being requested
of that it's 120 million a general funds
16 million of other funds
which to note its Liquor Commission is
the 16.4 millions of other funds in this
document
and then 36 million dollars in in
federal funds
the way it works with the bonding the
federal funds aren't bonded that's a
cash it's a match or or it's going to be
part of the project what's bonded would
be the general funds other funds and
Highway funds and what the treasurer
does is she goes out and bonds for a
number we'll just say 60 million dollars
in a particular year
and from that the treasure would know
that 5 million is related to a highway
fund Bond 2 million is related to a
other funds the rest is General funds
and they would charge the home fund
their portion of the debt service
so
when you're looking at the page one
University system of New Hampshire 17
million dollar appropriation I just want
the committee to remind the committee
this is an appropriation that was made
in the 2019 capital budget
so in that budget they there were three
Appropriations made to the university
system one for that year one that's in
the 2223 capital budget and then this
one for the 24 25 capital budget
yes representative
uh just a quick question thank you
um
I'm not sure at the county level we're
going through the the budget system and
we have arpa funds that are available
for us to use and I was just curious if
at a state level there's also arpa funds
that are available and if so did this
budget reflect
like especially like through I.T stuff
where it's a one-time purchase
is that
something it's already been addressed
through arpa or is is used in a
different direction
so the arpa funds come through the
governor's office special office called
gopher governor's office
something something
there is no arpa funds in this capital
budget that you see before you
their
have been arpa funds appropriated
through the fiscal committee so they
come through the fiscal committee on an
accept and expend basis under RSA 1430
and there are some projects that would
be considered capital projects that are
being funded through arpa and and there
are some I.T projects that are
specifically being funded through arpa
but it is not being included in the
capital budget nor directly into the
operating budget
there may be some
in some bills you may see Appropriations
that
um
direct that if arpa funds are available
use those and then if they're not
available find other federal funds and
if those aren't available use General
funds but those are specific
bills that have been introduced with
that language
so
this is good yeah
yes representative yes the follow-up on
that is there a list of
Opera funds that may have been spent for
things that were used for capital
projects that had previously been in
here in other words their duplication of
numbers
um
no there shouldn't be duplication of
numbers so there shouldn't be a project
in here that is funded elsewhere but is
that the question these projects are
Standalone and these are the first
funding that they're looking for
um there is if you go to the Gopher
website they do have a um a document on
there that shows you how much of the
arpa funds have been
um
appropriated or or assigned
and as you scroll through that document
it will show you they group them you
know is it for travel and tourism is it
for water projects is it for
um IT projects is it for
you know whatever it might be so they
group it and then it also assigns what
the fiscal committee item was if you
needed more details so you could find
that through the fiscal committee and
see what they provided thank you yep
seeing no further
so again the the governor's recommended
capital budget
it's going to look something like what
you'll get when House Bill 25 is
available
so again that's why we we've instructed
the agencies to use this we're hoping
that you'll get House Bill 25 possibly
by the end of next week
um but we make no promises uh
and then if you turn to page six of this
document
you're going to see a variety of pieces
of language some of it I talked about
being the can language there's the
Authority for the Appropriations and
then starting on page seven are all the
laps lapse extensions that are going to
be requested
again House Bill 25 when you receive it
will look very similar they'll be a
little bit structurally different but
it'll be a similar layout
insert any other questions did I create
more confusion
I don't have much more than that I think
um Lottery is here
um they're due at 10 30 so we've got six
minutes but sure I think we'll uh oh I'm
sorry
that's okay Mr chairman thank you Chris
thanks for the presentation I appreciate
it I want to Circle back to lapse
extensions because
I know that this is like the beginning
of my second term but I've
on the municipal level we've never used
lapse extensions on the municipal I just
what what causes a lap extension to
occur are you just just kind of a newbie
kind of question so
so I'm an agency that was received a
million dollars to do a roof replacement
we put it out to bid
first we figured out who we could send
it out you know what the bidding process
would be we put it out the bid we made
the decision
um
project gets delayed because the bids
that came back didn't fit what we
thought was going to be the cost there
we maybe need to go back and rework that
so by the time we get the project
reworked and rebid it's now spring
of
May of this year
and if you don't get the project lapse
extension your authority to spend that
money goes away June 30 2023.
so the reason that they use it in the
capital budget in this way is that it
allows everybody to be aware of what's
being requested to go forward and this
committee takes an opportunity to have
the agencies to explain what's the
status of this project what's happening
why is there delays
when do you think you're going to get it
done
are you ever going to get it done should
we consider maybe not doing that project
so so that it's a way to force the
project to be looked at one more time
instead of just giving them an open
appropriation that doesn't expire or
lapse they have to come back after every
two years and ask for a lapse extension
and then it makes you allows you to to
view it again and make sure that it's
heading in the direction that the
committee thought it was going to head
in okay good deal thank you I appreciate
it you're welcome
um Bruce can you explain if if the money
is no longer needed for a project or
there's excess money left over how do
that fits into this process can we
reappropriate that
energy
so if you go back to page 25 of the um
the document
the orientation document that I gave you
top of the page
it's a
10 section 107 colon 12 lapse of Prior
Capital Bud uh Capital balance Highway
funds Capital Appropriations for the
Department of Safety you'll see under
Roman one
there's two projects identified under a
and b
excuse me let me back up just a second
if you look in row three it says the
amount of 369 000 and change
is hereby labsed and then right after
that it identifies two projects those
are two projects that were completed
and in our review and working with the
agency during when this capital budget
was being built was determined that
there would be about 369 thousand
dollars total between the two projects
that could be repurposed or reused
um and then under
row 10 you'll see there's a sum
appropriated
for a purpose and in this case it was to
the Department of Safety for their State
Police Hangar Construction
and then row 13 would just let the
treasurer know that the these are still
bonded funds
and then the treasurer keeps track of
this repurposed dollar
any further questions yes just to
clarify so in other words those projects
ran into Surplus they didn't know if it
spent that's correct perfect okay thank
you
what
so just one thing I didn't mention
um
you passed the capital budget and then
your work is done
there is a committee the capital budget
overview committee which some of you
will be members of
um that does look at capital budget
projects agencies will come in
provide status updates or they may come
in and ask for some um
so there's some limited ability to
transfer
Appropriations between projects that
were funded in the same capital budget
so the capital budget overview committee
is has the authority to approve the that
process so if there is a project a that
completes and there's a hundred thousand
dollar Surplus and there's a project B
that needs a hundred thousand dollars
and it's in the same capital budget so
it was in the 2021 capital budget for
example
um they can come to capital budget
overview and make the request to move
that hundred thousand over to complete
the other project that was
um that enough money wasn't funded for
so it's a way to basically the the
legislature has said we're allowing 120
million dollars to be bonded or whatever
the number is
for these projects we want these
projects done and it allows the agencies
to do some of that
capital budget overview also receives
quarterly reports on the status of all
the projects
um I didn't bring mine with me but
Department of administrative Services
provides this report to the committee so
you can see if you know at any time what
the kind of the status is of a project
is it in planning is it in building has
it been completed has it been delayed
for some reason
so
so now I'm really done talking
unless there's any questions
the um the Committees that Chris is
referring to uh capital budget overview
and long-range planning uh typically
meet quarterly and there is a meeting
scheduled for I believe the 10th of next
month which will happen in this room
before we meet so if you want to come by
and see the excitement that happens
there you're you're more than welcome to
come by for that so
and the member the membership from our
committee has has already been named so
I remember as a freshman going up to my
chairman and saying I'd love to be on
that committee and he said it's
typically not there but yeah I was
always invited to those meetings with
him so
I think once you see a couple of those
you'll be pretty well filled in but I
believe it's a 10th and I believe we
start at uh nine o'clock for those two
meetings so with that Chris I really
appreciate the time that you've spent
here with us and Chris will be with us
or one of his uh assistants will be with
us through most of the process so I
appreciate your time thank you
foreign
so we will now move to our Lottery
Commission
um and
Jim Durham's Chief Financial Officer for
the Hampshire Lottery Commission I'm
sorry name again sir Jim Doris I'm a
little bit stuffy today no uh no problem
welcome to public welcome to Public
Works
so uh this will probably be a little
more different than what you're used to
but uh as you all know Lottery is
self-funded
uh for example when we purchased our
building that was not purchased by the
general fund it was purchased by the New
Hampshire lottery Enterprise fund
so going into the budget process this
year
we are unsure how to handle things a
little bit so we were advised that we
could put our requests into the capital
budget request and we also put it as a
digital prioritized need in our
operating budget
which would of course use our funds
rather than general fund to do the
project
in the governor's budget he did accept
those prioritized needs
um as part of our operating budget for
the year
so what we are proposing to do is
withdraw our request for a capital
budget
that's wonderful sir
does anyone have any questions for the
Lottery Commission
if I could while I have you here so that
um that building sits away from the main
campus and across the river correct and
that you had said earlier that that
building was purchased yes and owned by
The Lottery Commission yes okay we we
purchased the building
2019 uh we did it through a commercial
loan from a private bank
um after two and a half years we
outright paid off the note and took
ownership of full ownership of the
building at that time thank you sir
yes please representative I'll take
credit for that one uh I put that in the
budget because the director assured me
that they could pay the note on the
building for equal or less than what the
rent was going to be and there was
insecurity if they didn't do that of
their ability to stay any kind of
long-term uh contract the the owner of
the building was considering selling
elsewhere and it just seemed to
secure it and to give them extra
incentive and we put it in the budget we
authorized them to buy the building and
if the landlord wouldn't sell we
authorized them to build on campus which
incented the
the owner
thank you thank thank you for the
history too representative and
and your continued hard work
anyone else have any questions for
Audrey
thank you sir and thank you for bringing
good news thank you
so to our our advantage those funds then
we will we will have an opportunity to
discuss where those funds uh will be
distributed as we go along
and we'll hold a lot of that
conversation for after we've heard the
the needs of of all the Departments and
then we'll start through that process
um I would just like to go back to
something that represent Shea said
um to note chairman Graham sitting in
the audience
um our our capital budget if if it's if
it's if we during the process we will
work our way through this we may not all
agree on each and every item but in the
past and I knowing the group as I do now
will reach a consensus before we're done
here
and when we get to that point and before
it comes to the house floor it's going
to be important that you communicate
with the people that sit around you
uh and say you know this is why we came
here because it's not always totally
pleasing to the whole legislature but if
we talk about it and the we have a
reputation in the house of working
together and we will still so speak to
people about it if they have questions I
really don't like this bring it to John
bring it to myself
so that we can incorporate that and it
has been the pleasure of
most every chairman that I have been
here that when we reach the floor
we will we will pass over a hundred
million dollars on a Voice vote and
that'll be a credit to this committee
when we get there so just keep that in
mind if you hear issues bring them to us
and we will try and head off any small
fires before it happens so with that we
have the luxury of 20 minutes yes
the the committee of conference on last
year's capital budget was 10 minutes so
that was also non-controversial exercise
thank you Brandon so the committee of
conference is uh we've sent it to the
Senate the Senate sends it back to us
and if we don't agree then we choose and
we will choose to uh
um to have that conversation and that's
what the committee of conference is
about so if you didn't know what that
was that'll take part in uh in a in a
room senators and representatives and we
thrash that out and it hasn't been as
representative Jack says hasn't been
overly controversial for a number of
years so
so if there's no further questions at
this point treat yourself to 20 minutes
thank you
foreign
time being 11 o'clock we will now
continue with the governor's office
and listen to the budget director James
is it Gary or Jerry it's Gary Gary thank
you sir thank you for the committee the
governor's Offices here so we brought
out the big
the big banger go ahead sir
okay
uh good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is James Gary and
I'm the budget director for the State of
New Hampshire and as such I'm here to
present the governor's capital budget
for fiscal years 2024 and 2025. I plan
on giving a brief presentation overview
on you know really get to the point of
why we
chose to fund the projects we did and
then open up to the floor for any
questions for the committee members
as the state emerged from the covid
pandemic we saw a pent-up demand for
capital projects in the last two years
remarked by supply chain shortages as
well as large price increases for both
materials and labor that is if you could
find those items at all
so under that guys last spring the
department of administrative Services
put out the call for any departments in
the state excuse me the head Capital
needs to submit their proposals
typically the capital budget that the
governor submits is usually in the 120
maybe upwards of 130 million dollar
range
for this capital budget we received
requests for 750 million dollars of
projects to be funded from the general
fund with total projects including those
from other state sources and federal
revenue to totaling over just over one
billion dollars
now typically when you get requests like
this uh you see about maybe it's about
10 percent uh that's a rough figure
which I would call fluff and when I
Define fluff as as a want not a need
it's not something that is irrelevant to
something you would never fund but it's
typically something that's not needed
more that's wanted now if you want to
fund 130 million dollars of projects and
140 million dollars of requests come in
and you cut the 10 the 10 of fluff off
you can do that and still be within your
targets however when you have 750
million dollars of general fund requests
and you're looking to get down to 130
million and you cut the 10 off or that
leaves you 675 675 million you know
which is still as a magnitude of five of
where we want to be
so uh obviously uh and clearly
significant Cuts had to be had to be
made
our goals when we decided to fund these
projects were as follows we wanted to
leverage as much Federal money to the
fullest extent possible
we wanted to spread out funding so that
no one department or government sector
got significantly more than the rest
and we want to be sure that no one
project was disproportionately funded
the result of this exercise is what we
present here in the capital budget
the governor submitted a list of 15
departments for 42 separate projects
totaling 247.4 million overall with
129.9 million coming from general fund
sources
16.8 million coming from other revenues
and 99.8 million coming from federal
sources
this of course meant that three-quarters
of a billion dollars of projects were
not funded via this capital budget
despite the requests if we chose not to
fund a project that is not a statement
on whether the project is a worthwhile
project but rather is it a statement of
not only our prioritization but their
prioritization and in a mechanism that
allows the state to live within its
means
so given our goals of keeping the
general fund portion under 130 million
dollars fund a diverse set of
departments and project types all the
while to the extent possible leveraging
as much federal dollars as possible this
meant that roughly 25 percent of the
total project requests could be funded
and only 20 percent of the general fund
projects could be funded as well
now when the governor opened a capital
budget hearings this past July he spoke
about funding part of the state's
capital projects or Surplus from the FY
uh fiscal year 23 budget in fact the
governor is proposing proposing in hb2
an additional 224.5 million in projects
to be funded with fiscal year 23 Surplus
it should be noted that a significant
portion of these projects are not your
typical capital projects rather they are
grants designed designed to address
significant needs of the state and
they include a 30 million dollar grant
for invest NH which will fund up to 1
000 new housing units 25 million dollar
grant for the affordable housing fund a
4.5 million dollar uh grant for a
computer science initiative that will
have a direct impact on every public
middle school and high school in the
state and 10 million dollars for an
initial down payment for a new state
prison for men in Concord that will
replace the existing structure
with that there are a few projects that
I want to bring to your attention that
have changed since the last submission
one I believe you are aware of uh the
875 thousand dollars for the Lottery
Commission is no longer requested uh we
we did fund
a maintenance request for them in their
operating budget and they believe that
will be sufficient so the 875 that's
here now is no longer requested you have
something else I want to bring your
attention is the 10.5 million dollar
request for the Department of Education
and for that that's that is to purchase
their basically their headquarters where
they where they operate out of and it's
25 Hall Street and the original budget
request for that was seven million
dollars
and that was based off of uh that it is
a sale between UNH and and the New
Hampshire's Department of Education UNH
currently owns the building and the
initial price of seven million dollars
was based on the fact of a commercial
real estate expert that UNH consulted
who uh did some comparables some comps
and and gave out that seven million
dollar figure uh it was not an official
appraisal it was not an official asking
price it was just the back of the
envelope type but based off of an
expert's opinion
uh and when the administrative Services
uh priced it out uh I think as as I hear
often on legal shows they assume facts
that were not in evidence and the uh The
price came back at 10.5 million that
that is not the price uh the real price
will be determined Upon A an appraisal
an official appraisal that will have to
be done on the project so it can be done
at sort of an arms links transaction as
much as possible between those two
entities and that will be that will be
the price uh uh UNH and Department of
Education are not expecting that uh
appraisal to be significantly different
than the seven million dollars that they
uh banded about last July so that
request as well probably should come
down by a couple of million dollars
yeah and with that I'll gladly open up
to any questions
you may have
thank you before I do that so
uh do you have any idea when that
negotiation will finally be entered will
it be while the capital budget is still
within the house or is that at a time
when it goes to the Senate that is my
hope
um if you know upon upon with
consultation to you and upon your
direction we can we can give them but I
don't think they need to go ahead from
me or certainly from us to do it but I
think getting it this is the project you
are likely to fund then I think that
getting an appraisal done uh very
quickly is is so you know what you're
dealing with would be the way to go that
that would be helpful
um and just for background the
university didn't own that building for
an awful long time did they was it in
less than 10 years or so I believe so
yes and and when they took possession of
that building were there millions of
dollars worth of Renovations are you
aware of that they had done to that bill
building I'm not aware the renovations
they've done I do know that the doe is
actually in that building now and
they've been renting it from the
University so they're they're clearly
happy with the building they want to buy
it and it certainly fits their needs as
is okay thank you
okay thank you
um May I
representative did you have a question
uh yes Mr chairman if you don't mind a
question I appreciate the overall
presentation Mr Gary but in fact this is
about the Department of Education and I
was just curious if you could tell us
the governor's thinking about why for
the first time in 20 years since I've
been on this committee there is no
funding for any ctes in his capital
budget requests for the first time and
I'm as I said so if you could tell us
anything about why the governor did not
include any funding please thank you
okay there actually is funding for for
ctes in the budget there's uh there
there were two that were submitted uh
there was that the Newport CTE which I
believe was roughly around 11 million
dollars and then there was the Tilton
CTE for the winus Guam School District
which was around six million dollars we
funded the larger request which was the
the Newport CTE the the Tilton CTE was
not funded for a variety of reasons
first and foremost it has not gone
before the voters yet while the Newport
CTE has been approved by the local
voters that Tilton one has not yet I
believe their
their that goes before the voters at
their town meeting which I believe is
right around March it's uh March 25th or
something along those lines and so we'll
know more than
in addition to that we view any sort of
request uh in in the context not only is
the request good and you know should we
fund it because we do support and the
government does support ctes but it has
to be viewed in the overall context and
the overall context of the department of
education budget this budget increases
the department of education's uh funding
by over nine percent which is the
largest increase in over 20 years in
addition to that we're spending over 100
million dollars of building aid for for
other schools across the state state to
get built and
um
yeah in addition to that we look at
their prioritized needs list on their
prioritized needs list there were five
things requested the the Tilton CTE
Center was number four out of five so uh
again had it been approved by the voters
we may have had a different viewpoint on
it but we have you know if we if we put
that in and then it doesn't get approved
by the voters we've taken that's six
million dollars away from something else
on the list that we would have had to
have cut
yes Mr chairman thank you a question
when you say funding so it's not in the
in the capital budget though House Bill
20 if it's in it's in another budget the
funding for Newport
uh it is in the cap it is it is an hp2
when it's HP tool okay I just wanted to
be sure it's not in the capital budget
you're ready and I'm I'm familiar just
for everybody in the committee because
it's uh of the Newport because I know
it's been approved the local share
because it's in my area so but I want to
be very clear as far as newport's
concerned but thank you for contribution
but it is an hp2 yes sir
um yes representative Jefferson thank
you chairman uh director Jerry you you
mentioned uh
funding for school buildings are these
and I didn't catch it are these new
school buildings or these improvements
and repairs
their improvements in repairs
there's existing schools updated and
upkeep and maintenance on existing
schools you got it thank you thank you
and uh for the representative
um it has been traditional when more
monies have been there that we renovate
two of these and over the course of uh
10 years we have come back to each one
of these uh schools and made
improvements what's starting to happen
is as
gentlemen is mentioned the cost factor
is becoming so high or the want of the
uh the community is so high that it's
making it difficult to fully fund but
it's always been a very high priority of
this uh committee thank you if I could
ask so there's no Community College
money in here can you explain to me is
that coming in somewhere else or could
you tell me what the governor's thoughts
is on that place the Community College
um one was was a tough one
um and if we had more money that's you
know I think that's where it would have
been funded what we did this year was uh
we had a priority to them of of
increasing their budget after being flat
funded for a number of bienniums we
increased their operating budget roughly
by 13 percent
uh but the the bottom line is is that
the community college system and it may
be a little unfair to them was crowded
out by the university system uh
six years ago the state made a
commitment to the university system to
fund their capital projects and I
believe it was 10 million in the first
biennium 15 million in the second and 17
million in this biennium and with that
and some other projects we're funding in
hb2 as I mentioned
um
allowing uh or keeping the
the no one government sector or part of
government to have a very large impact
on the capital budget or or
what we did in hb2 was tandem out and
the university system took up basically
a lot of the oxygen the other thing was
uh and and this is more of a capital
what is a capital project debate a lot
of their projects were and I think badly
needed uh maintenance where that
maintenance is ongoing maintenance or a
true Capital maintenance meaning it
lasts Beyond five years and it's
something you can legitimately bond for
uh is is a question but I do believe
they they absolutely have needs and uh
if they're not addressed in this budget
whether it's myself or whoever is doing
it two years from now uh you know with
with the commitment to the university
system
gone I was looking for the community
colleges to step up to the plate
thank you for that sir other questions
yes represent Boyd
thank you Mr chairman Mr Gary thank you
for for your testimony today
um
dovetailing off of the off of the
Chairman's questions regarding community
colleges was there any Community College
that offered a project that obviously
they didn't make the cut but was right
there that got a lot of consideration
that might be worthy of this committee's
attention yeah I believe when they when
they submitted that they only had a
couple of requests and they they didn't
uh you know when they put in the request
they did not do it as an individual
project but they did it as a list of
projects where they said maintenance for
these facilities
and uh it it I would say they came very
close uh because again
um
critical maintenance of facilities is is
something that not only affects the
community college system but the state
as a whole if we took all 129 million
that we're proposing here and you gave
it to commissioner arlinghaus and said
you know do maintenance with this he
would say thank you that's a good down
payment
and uh because that's what maintenance
it is and what the status of Maintenance
as it is today and it's only been
exacerbated uh over the last three years
since March of 2020 because you know due
to
uh funding you know lack of funding
because we obviously had a significant
drop in revenues during that time the
initial time and then with supply chain
issues and pricing increases doing the
maintenance
uh was was
almost impossible to do you know so the
need is there the news there throughout
the state but you know I would say yes
they're very close
thank you uh representative Boyd and I
will come to you sir in a moment and no
disrespect to the governor's budget uh
we will we will ask
departments when they come
um you know what were some of the needs
that you felt you know you should have
and I'm not saying that we are going to
agree that money but we'll at least
we'll we'll look at that internally and
see if there's some wiggle room
somewhere so representative
my feeling this is my fourth term
has been
to try and stay as close to the
governor's budget as possible
the reason is everybody votes for him
not everybody votes for me
what all the things you're saying could
be very helpful to us if we knew
what he cut
and why
so that we at least have some argument
whether we agree with him or not
so some kind of printed document on the
cuts he made relative to our budget that
we have to come up with
would be helpful
okay that's possible uh
it's
I'll have to think whether it's possible
or not uh but one thing I can I can say
and this sort of addresses your question
sir as well is that this is the
governor's capital budget proposal it's
it's now your capital budget right and
it's free for you to work on and and
what
my job is going to be over the next few
months until June 30th is to work with
you because it eventually it is the
governor's budget proposal it's now your
budget and eventually it's going to have
to become our budget and so to work
closely with you and uh we we fully
realize that while these are our
priorities your priorities May differ
and we can if you have projects that uh
certainly you're you're interested in in
funding and uh you know replacing some
of the proposals we've made we can we
can certainly work with you on that and
I can
do my best in coming up with a with a a
better uh explanation as to which
projects we're in and which projects
were out again the scope is is very
large it's you know roughly
850 well well 750 million dollars of
projects were cut so it's a big task
uh thank you thank you both I believe uh
touche mentioned in the beginning one of
our documents has all of the requests by
departments that were brought to the
governor so we have we have that list
and
um we will as each department comes in
if you want to cue in on where that was
and we asked them
um you know if there was something that
you know didn't make the list you know
will will start compiling that list and
when we get to the end you know we may
have a possibility of a couple million
dollars here and eight hundred thousand
dollars there we we as a group will will
figure that out so I don't think we need
to burden the gentleman on that so any
other questions yes represent counter
yeah
um thank you Mr chairman um do you know
who's in charge of uh like uh Bridges uh
as far as maintenance and building or
rebuilding it would depend on which
Bridge uh if their state on is it's the
department of obviously it runs through
the Department of Transportation okay
but many of our bridges are locally
owned okay uh as well so it really
depends on on which bridge I imagine
there are obviously some federal as well
but okay thank you
anyone else at this time
thank you sir me thank you very much
again any questions uh please feel free
to reach me
Chris knows exactly how to get hold of
me so yeah thank you I appreciate the
Open Line and we've spoken so thank you
thank you
um
so we have we have one more hearing at
11 30 Department of Information
Technology
and then we will be going to uh luncheon
coming back for one o'clock
and
this shade you have something else to
add I just wanted to um
respond to representative's question so
the agencies that are coming before you
have been asked to
um not only talk about what's been
incorporated into the governor's
recommended capital budget but to also
bring forward any items that they feel
that they would still like to have
considered
for a capital project so I think to to
go out kind of um dovetail on what
director Gary was saying you know
there's some fluff maybe there's some
projects that can wait but then there
may be critical projects and those are
what the agencies will come I believe
and talk to you about if it didn't get
included in the in the capital budget
secondly the reference to House Bill 2
so there are some projects that are
being funded through House Bill 2 uh the
prison I think representative that's not
representative Gary director Gary
mentioned that as well as the CTE our
office has put together a preliminary
listing of the House Bill 2
Appropriations based on what the
governor's budget contained I can make
copies of that and bring that back to
the committee it's also on our website
um
but
to to the point that director Gary was
making there are some truly what you
would have seen as capital projects
coming through here as well as projects
that you might not otherwise have seen
But due to the Surplus that the uh the
governor is recommending they be funded
okay please yes Mr Shea isn't I've been
told that I mean hb1 that basically an
HB 25 the the operating budget and
capital budget have been released but
the trailer bill which is House Bill 2
all the details haven't been released
yet are is that correct
so House Bill 2 is is being drafted
right now by office legislative Services
it's a fairly extensive document so it's
going to take a little bit of time
um for those for their attorneys to get
that completed
um so no it hasn't been released
um in House Bill 2 format the governor's
office transmitted to the office of
legislative services to um draft just as
they did House Bill 25 and House Bill
one house bill one is a fairly easy
document to produce so that has been
introduced
um
the house bill 25 and House Bill 2 takes
a little bit more in terms of the
drafting associated with that it's
basically making sure the legislation
that's being cited in there or changed
is not impacting other legislation
throughout our statutes so it does take
a few moments for them to get that done
on top of
um
everything else that OLS is doing on a
day-to-day with the Committees and
getting ready for session
um
I think I heard it I heard somebody also
talk about the revenues or make a
comment about the revenues revenues are
on track
so the
I believe the chair's desire is to try
to finalize those next week
which is in line with prior years
it's actually if I look back
three budgets ago it would be a week
earlier two budgets ago be a week right
on the last budget it's a week later
however
um
last budget the Ways and Means Committee
did come up with its revenues and the
finance committee asked the ways and
means to go back and re-look at their
revenues so they had a second set of
revenues come out later in March
quick follow-up request yeah could you
yeah if you could email us copies of
what the projects that are in-house Bill
to especially because I'm interested in
the Newport CTE and to help answer any
questions constituents who are concerned
about this issue if you could send us
send us this information I would
appreciate it please I'll send an email
to the entire committee with the
document attached to it I can bring hard
copies if the desire is there for that
as well
oh I'm sorry uh representative
I didn't want to be misunderstood
it's not that I'm going to agree with
all the governor's cuts my concern is
that the final number
is that we create as close to the final
number
as we can so but any information that's
available is so we we can make a
decision one way or the other is going
to be helpful
okay
and and not to be
um
so the binder that was sitting here that
I moved over to there those were all the
requests that were made
this this is what
was all the requests made to the
governor
this is what made it out so you have the
the summary list for this document
what's in here
whatever didn't make it into this green
document is what the governor said we
we're not going to fund for whatever
reason
and and that book will stay on my desk
in in there and you're free to come in
anytime look through that
um and you know be able to formulate
your questions from there
and there was no offense taken by your
question anyways represent
so are there anyone else for because
we're just about right yes go right
ahead I do want to get as much detail as
you can get on the prison
for
I used to has had bigger chunks change
constantly dumped and I'm not thrilled
with it's not going through here so
Department of Corrections is scheduled
to come talk to you I did ask them to
speak specifically about that project
with you
um
I will reiterate that with the
commissioner
anyone else
yes representative thank you just
following up on representative Eaton's
question if they bring some pictures
also if they have them of things that
are in distress
I'm sure they will they usually do yeah
I I just want to point out and that
perhaps uh Miss Shea in your
conversations
uh Summer of the understanding that the
construction practices for the women's
prison may not have come out the way we
were intended and we just want to we
want to have some assurance that the
project going forward will we will have
learned from our past so
I think that's quietly there right any
anyone else because we will uh let Mr
Shea move to the back of the room thank
you sir
and uh gentlemen would just give it a
couple minutes so we're on schedule for
when it's when it's done thank you
time being 11 30 we are going to move on
to the Department of Information
Technology uh gentlemen welcome to
Public Works
please just introduce yourself and tell
us what you have
patience
right thank you
that's like not hitting me unmuting on
the zoom right yeah but you're the
technology guy
I'll start over uh good morning Mr chair
and members of the committee my name is
Dennis Goulet I'm the commissioner for
the Department of Information Technology
and with me today is Ken Dunn the Deputy
Commissioner
that we're happy to be here today to
present the governor's proposed I.T
portion of the capital budget requests
starting out on page two There's a
summary which includes all of the all of
the it really or what was identified as
it related capital projects that are
were funded in the governor's budget
Governor's proposed budget and the
requested amount how much of that would
be general or federally funded and uh
and the totals for each category I'll
take you through each of those projects
moving on to page three you see the
agency technology requests that were
funded by uh in the governor's budget
one from Environmental Services two from
HHS and one from energy
or for the new members sir could you
just explain
dcyf and the word Bridges and how that
doesn't relate to highway bridges sure
I'll take in fact we'll get to I have
some detail on all of those sounds good
well thank you I'll make sure I get into
that thank you
um moving on to page four the
Environmental Services project
basically there's a current capital
funded project that was that's been in
process during this biennium to
um
Implement uh what they're calling uh
their modernization of their One-Stop
One Stop is there
um
agency specific place where you go to
get services on their website and the
applications themselves are pretty old
and they're not as friendly to the to
the community as they could be so that
process is ongoing right now and the
agency is requesting additional funds to
keep doing that and you can see it's
pretty pretty extensive they have
you know 200 individual programs that
they that they want to consolidate into
a single way of doing business and a
single
data structure so we can get better they
actually have a mountain of valuable
information that's a bit hard to get to
because it's it's all over the place so
we're working closely with the agency on
that project and we'll continue to do so
should this be funded
um
basically some other details there
associated with it in the um in addition
to the one stop
under additional I.T needs
moving on to page five
and here's where we get to Bridges
so so this is your
Bridges is uh is a code name for a
system that's been in place for many
many years that was supporting the child
welfare system and uh
and they use some some technology stuff
here current states a 23 year old Power
Builder power Builder what does that
mean it's a real old
um uh really actually was in its day was
a really good application development
platform
um and clearly it's it's still running
today so um it's still pretty solid but
you can't find people that will that can
actually work on it and it's not well
supported so it really does need an
upgrade this is really moving into a
multi-biennium project that that needs
to keep going to both
um
be compliant with Federal funding but
also and and really I think really
importantly to modernize how we process
data in that so that the folks who are
out there um
in you know supporting children and and
helping to keep them safe are actually
doing less work to input their data and
having that data be input in a more
accurate fashion so that a higher
percentage of the time is being spent on
what their core mission is versus
managing data
that's
moving on to I'm happy to take questions
and as they go along or at the end
I think we'll take them at the end okay
the the next one on page six is the um
electronic health records system
basically what this would do is uh for
for the benefit of the committee and and
members who are listed are folks who are
listening in electronic health records
is really the heart and soul of of you
know if you're thinking about if you
were in a hospital or an emergency room
or whatever that's the system that keeps
track of everything they're pretty large
systems complex and
um and basically most most health care
institutions couldn't live without them
in in these days because of the the um
you know the amount of information
that's carried in there today in uh HHS
they have you know multiple systems that
are supporting different parts of their
business this this project would bring
together
all of the known electronic health
records requirements and support some
new things that we have coming on
um including the
the uh the new forensic Hospital
and you can see at the very last bullet
there it's pretty extensive on how many
people would be using it and how many
external entities would also be
um be uh have access to in it to help us
you know better serve as a as an
integrated community
and finally uh last agency project is
energy
um I know we we talk about
um you know
this committee's often talking about
buildings so the this is an analog to
the their current system is the analog
to that building and that the roof has
needed to be replaced for a decade but
hasn't been so it's been leaking and
causing internal damage so that's kind
of the analog here to Energy System they
really need this in fact when I joined
the state in 2015 I this function was
over in the um uh strategic initiatives
group and they were talking about
needing it to be replaced eight years
ago so so it is pretty pretty much in
need and particularly now you know
driving efficiency and Effectiveness in
the aid that we're able to give out in
the in the energy sector through this
LIHEAP program I think it's it's a it's
a good and important project
so that that really concludes all the
agency projects that were
proposed under the governor's capital
budget now I'm going to move on to the
doit projects
the first one and this has been
before we go there uh are there are
there questions on the first part of
this presentation yes represent Barber
ah thank you Mr chairman uh my curiosity
is what does a roof have to do with I.T
uh I I know the building needs a new
roof as you said but I'm information
technology
has nothing to do with Roofing
um well it it really is it was an it was
an analog
um
uh but basically
um if you neglect an I.T system
it has similar effects to neglecting a
building in terms of the effectiveness
of that system
I believe we need a little more
explanation for the gentleman
um
okay
I I believe we're struggling with the
word I.T
analog in your reference to the roof
um I I was just make making a comparison
um you know when you look at um
making comparison when you look at um
you know we we struggle to keep our
buildings uh maintained and and and we
have a similar situation for some of our
I.T systems as well so my apologies for
not being clear on that
thank you representative Jack uh thank
you Mr chairman and thank you it's good
to see you uh you have money over on the
Child Welfare you have money in 21 and
you have money in 19 and this is now uh
if I understand what you've said
correctly this would be the last time
you would need the more money for the
child welfare you expect to wrap it up
in this biennium that's my understanding
sir
represent Boyd might have to move you
closer over here that's okay I like it
here okay representative Edgar is
keeping me honest all right thank you Mr
chairman uh commissioner thank you very
much for
your presentation so far
um looking at the the bridges
replacement
um and I apologize if this is a little
bit sensitive but
um dcyf unfortunately has had two issues
as it relates to two two children that
that fell through the CIS that fell
through the cracks for the lack of a
better term are these enhancements going
to allow our dcfy
dcyf work is being able to have a more
higher level of access to information so
that they're able to do their job more
effectively and more timely
yes sir
um part of part of the the desire here
is to have
better access to information while
they're in the field but also um a a an
ability to update information more
easily while in the field so that should
that should serve uh to make them I
think more effective
just a quick follow-up thank you
um I'm not
I shouldn't say this because my wife and
I we adopted our daughter through dcyf
and I'm trying to remember what her
caseworker always brought when we are in
the process of fostering to adopt it but
are are these caseworkers equipped with
like an iPad or some type of an app on
their phone where they're documenting
information real time and then it's
being transmitted
the the bridges system uh that exists
today isn't isn't particularly strong in
that in that case for the you know
managing remotely so that's one of the
big improvements that's desired to make
with so they'll it'll synchronize yes
perfect yeah actually it wouldn't need
to synchronize it all be it be real time
perfect okay thank you thank you uh
thank you for the question the um I want
to go to uh DS which I believe was the
first one you talked about in the ones
one stop
tool is used all the time it's wonderful
and the department wanting to finally
scan in all of the um I think right now
if you were to look for a septic design
online it'd have to be from like 2005 so
they're trying to go backwards and make
those documents because they're
extremely hard to find and we keep
spending valuable time going to pull out
documents so I I applaud that that
that's happening the issue is with
another department by Environmental
Services which is Shoreland and wetlands
and while they use the service it is not
friendly to the residents who are
looking for information
do you know if Des could start working
some of those that paperwork into this
stream so it can be seen because there
are no documents here right or if that
is a future project Capital project that
they're coming with
um that there's another initiative going
on now that's has been funded with arpa
funds for permitting
and we're in fact we just brought on
um this week the program manager to run
with it and and it's a it's a permitting
project that was funded for D.O.T and
Des and the idea there is to very
significantly modernize the permitting
processes and there's a bunch of them in
in Des
and that
Wetlands is one of the ones we're
thinking we're looking for those first
use cases to you know in other words
we'd like to add capabilities in an
incremental fashion so we're not waiting
until we're done everything to add value
in in certain places and and Des is
considering the the wetlands as one of
the early use cases that we would um we
would tackle
I I would hope it continues on that way
for the new members
um when that when monies were hard to
find and
um you sir have mentioned this before
the uh when we started in with computer
systems in the state instead of buying
products that were out there whether
products software and I'm messing this
up representative Jack I'm sure but
um so we had some ingenious employees
and others that started coding and
making programs and we used them for a
long time and and then those departments
would come in and they want to spend
more time to this but then people were
retiring and the people that were
maintaining these for the new members
were no longer available and we were in
a true bind and your department sir was
charged with funneling a lot of if I
remember correctly funnel a lot of those
projects through them so that we and
others had a good understanding ending
that this was the best way to do it and
I believe in many cases now as you're
hearing now with the bridges that we're
we're finally getting to that point and
it's it's under your oversight and I'm
I'm very appreciative of of that work
that you do and another benefit too and
that and I should have mentioned this as
it relates to Bridges but it also it
holds true here what we find is when if
we have cyber security assessments we
find that the older systems are much
more likely to have vulnerabilities in
them because of you know it wasn't a
thing that people cared about 20 25
years about ago and it's it's a big deal
now so you may Mr chair you may recall
when we took down a lot of those ones
those One-Stop systems because we found
some significant vulnerabilities and we
wanted to protect citizen data so we
took them down and then we incrementally
brought them back up once they were
remediated but that is the kind of thing
that we challenged we had with older
systems that we'd definitely like to
address
thank you sir are there any other
questions
thank you for coming thank you
oh sorry let's go
so I just get my my it ones yeah stay
um so um on page eight There's a summary
of the doit capital requests
um this is a little bit down I think
it's about a million and a half down
approved from um from last biennium I'm
not complaining it's just a statement of
fact
um we all we almost always prioritize
cyber security as number one and and the
reason is it's important but also the
bar keeps moving so what used was a good
job eight years ago wouldn't be adequate
today so so the bar keeps moving on us
we have to keep up with it and I'll go
into a little more detail on that when
we get to the the detail part of it the
financial systems modernization
um I I use the I use the comparison of
the landscaper's yard here right so a
lot of times you drive by a landscaper's
house in their yard doesn't look so good
because they're spending all their time
getting everybody else's yard looking
good that's that's what our financial
systems modernization is is a bit we
have we have some need to improve there
and then service management is is really
um a science and an art that helps us do
more with the people we have measure
ourselves better for Effectiveness so
I'll take you through that one by one
starting with page nine
so
the first bullet there is interesting
because what's happened in the cyber
security space is there's so much
information we are now Gathering
that we're having trouble with humans
keeping up with it and correlating and
figuring out what's good and isn't good
so you see these s-i-e-m and soar I'll
simplify that by saying that what that
does is modernize the way information is
is gathered and analyzed so that you
don't necessarily need human eyes on
something all the time to catch a
problem
there's just the volume of information
is is massive a small example would be
if a system is experiencing experiencing
an attempt
to log in as say an administrator what
we call elevated privileges which you
really don't want right attempts that
are failing
um you you want that to be automatically
noticed and alerted and maybe even shut
down without human intervention so
that's just one example of and that's
the kind of thing we that we we do track
but there's so much of the information
out there that it's hard to keep up with
so that's something we've we're seeing
in the industry in in the industries in
general and in other states that are are
modernizing their their abilities in
this area
identity and access management continues
to be a challenge are you really the
person we think you are and is it so you
have this challenge between wanting it
to be strong but also having it to be
consistent and easy enough so people
aren't writing passwords down and
defeating all the systems by virtue of
the fact that you made them so hard so
that's the challenge there and then this
National Institute of Standards and
Technology we've we've embarked on over
the past year or so embarked on a really
high discipline effort to to document
how we exist in reference or relative to
these standards and then measuring
ourselves against them and also having
third-party entities coming in
to test us to say all right all right
doit how are you doing on this and and
so we're we're Desiring to up our game
there
uh
so in the case of the uh
the uh desired end State we really want
to get better at analyzing and gathering
and analyzing information that we now
have in in and react to it more quickly
and and potentially in an automated
fashion
uh and we want to um
have a high discipline approach to
application of Standards so that we're
able to measure ourselves and and evolve
with the standards as they get stronger
that's it for the cyber security piece
I think we think we have a question yes
represent Boyd please
thank you Mr chairman again thank you
for your testimony
um
China the United States India and Brazil
are the top four countries where cyber
attacks originate from everybody would
think Russia Russia is actually actually
10th on the list as a state
how much do you think we're going to be
spending over the next one three five
ten years in
protecting our intellectual assets here
at the state as it relates to potential
cyber attacks not just you know our
physical plant here up in Concord but
any other site that the state of New
Hampshire relies on Information
Technology where there could be an
impact it could be the way that the
state police communicate with each other
Emergency Management that kind of
perspective I'm just kind of I mean I
mean I have no problem with the price
tag because I get it it's it's it's an
imminent threat I mean you could come
back here a week later and there's
something new that you're at you're
going to ask us to respond to so I think
for everybody here in the committee you
know
what are we looking at in terms of being
able to be prepared to to address any
any attacks well what I can say on that
is that the percentage of our total
spend
uh that's focused on cyber security type
activities keeps going up so when these
these Capital Appropriations help us
adapt and that's funded with capital but
it becomes operating expense in the next
biennium
so that you'll see that
um you'll see that if I put in a new
system for example to help automate
processes for keeping our our data
secure
that will likely result in operating
expense in the subsequent biennium
the other thing and you mentioned State
Police so I'll use that as an example
um there's a there's a standard that's
promulgated by the FBI called sieges
criminal justice information system and
see just we get audited by the FBI on a
regular basis and they look to see that
we're following this standard the
standard is really about
you know security of information and
appropriate use of law enforcement
information inside the department of
safety and other entities that do safety
related our department or law
enforcement related activities like
liquor enforcement would be an example
there so in addition to our own
activities there are activities that the
federal government agencies conduct
that audit us and and keep raising the
standards bar
so that and that layers in cost as well
so you know what you what we're observed
what I'm observing is a a greater
percentage of our time and effort and
Investments
are incrementally increasing over time
to adapt to this stuff
when you talk about foreign governments
there's and there's really two things
right there's the foreign governments
that you mentioned and then there's the
criminals and they may actually be the
same and they may not be the same and so
so we're seeing a lot of attempted
criminal activity as well that we have
to adapt to which is which is you know
either stealing money directly through
um through
fooling people which we've seen examples
of in New Hampshire and
um or Ransom ransoming your data and
then asking for money to get it back
additionally
um the the state and local cyber
security grant program that was funded
in the infrastructure Bill we are now
accepting funds through that program in
fact New Hampshire was the the one of
the first two states to get an approved
plan through
through um through DHS cisa and so we
now have we just went through fiscal and
governor and Council we have those funds
in Department of Safety and we're
beginning to we're going to begin to
expend those to support communities
around the state because you're required
to spend 80 percent of that money for
communities not State act cyber security
activities we're going to spend more
than 80 percent on the communities in
there we're really prioritizing that
money going out to the city's towns and
schools
in in the state additionally we're
funding uh training right now in
collaboration with a risk pool manager
in in New Hampshire to train anybody who
wants to be trained on basic stuff like
how to not get fooled and give your
money away to a criminal things like
that so so we are investing in that as
well because it's you know it doesn't
help the citizens if we're just doing it
the state but we're not doing it all
around it at these very other community
points so we're really spending a lot of
effort and we're taking it very
seriously
one follow-up one follow-up Mr chairman
thank you just a quick follow-up so
it's it's
every year every year could be coming
back to us for well every two years
excuse me every two years could be
updating technology to to keep what
you're to keep what we have versus we
have to buy some we have to buy
something new every two years to to
continually address the threat assuming
like using State Police is the example
the FBI may decide that there's a better
widget that the state of New Hampshire
needs to have as opposed to just you
know installing sieges 2.0 onto onto
your um
onto your server
thank you that that's a factor for sure
representative Jack uh thank you again
uh how close are we to finally getting
retired all of the Legacy 30 year old
hardware and software systems I know
we've I think last time you said you'd
started them all how close are we to
finishing getting all that in the rear
view well we're we're actually doing
well there I think the two the two
um the one remaining one that that I can
think of in terms of you know really old
Hardware which you're probably aware of
is is in Department of Labor which which
is a running uh an as400 there which
they're they're they have funding to to
move on to new technology in our uh
continuing to do so so
um Revenue retired there as 400 with
their new Revenue system and that's been
very successful that that project was on
time and on budget
we actually have a very large Mainframe
uh
Ken actually does a lot of work but it's
it it's not it's pretty modern actually
it's an IBM Z series Mainframe that runs
our integrated eligibility system so
that that one's not we don't necessarily
look at that as a technology debt maybe
a strategy change if we want to get off
it off of it but it's running
effectively as with pretty modern
technology now
representative we'll come down here just
real quick Dennis uh just as an
eye-opener can you give them a rough
number of how many attempted intrusions
we get per week or per month
um well a lot it continues to go up I
haven't seen the latest number but it's
it's it's you know tens of millions per
month
thank you and and uh well over 90 of all
inbound email
is intentionally not delivered to to
Executive Branch inboxes
um because of what we find in it
thank you is there someone else
yes representative Newman
yes thank you and
and probably awkwardly up
in it was October
um in depth New Hampshire did a story
and that's why I've got it Portsmouth
firm to negotiate cyber attacks for New
Hampshire in thief's native tongue all
right
after I saw the article I sent a message
to a a cyber friend of mine who teaches
and works in the field and he's
um he's good anyway his his comment on
that he didn't have a lot of
complementary things about that I sent
him the article but and this is what he
wrote to me it's better to establish
good practice and data data backup slash
recovery than to pay Ransom to Bad
actors and and he went on a little bit
so could I ask how confident are you on
backup data recovery and things like
that
so that's a really that's a great
question oh thank you
um and I and I agree with him
wholeheartedly
so so if you look at our cyber insurance
program
um that's part of the Cyber insurance
program by the way so you say okay I'm
gonna you know I never wanna pay a
ransom
ever
but what if I have to what if something
happened or somebody was more clever
than we were and we are faced with the
position of having to do so you want to
be able to do it effectively and that's
what that is about it's not about oh
paying a ransom is our strategy number
one it's actually the very last thing
the other thing I'll say is that the
ransomware actors have evolved
um so it used to be they would come and
they'd Ransom your data and then they'd
say all right give me money and I'll
give you the the key to get your data
back uh that's not what they're doing
anymore now what they're doing is
they're they get in they exfiltrate your
data
and then they Ransom it and so what
they'll tell you now is okay so I've got
backups we spend a lot of time thinking
about our backups
and and typically you know we had a
reasonable size ransomware attack in
2016 that we successfully uh mitigated
through putting the data back from
backups now you you're in the Specter of
accepting a data breach
if you if you tell the ransomware the
the person who's ransomed you to go away
so
on any given situation you know we're
going to try as hard as we can not to be
Ransom we've done a lot of work to to
see that we don't
um if we were to be Ransom we'd have to
look at that situation and say all right
what are we going to do here I've got
backups do we want to accept a data
breach or potential data breach because
that's what they're gonna the bad guys
are going to say all right well I know
you got a backup but I'm going to put
your info on the dark web if you don't
pay me
so
um so we might you know we we'd be faced
then with a policy decision on how we'd
want to go forward on that so it's it's
a complex Pro uh process but the one of
the things and one of the reasons why
native speakers are important is
there's going to be good communication
but also the attitudes it's there's
documented evidence that shows that the
attitudes of the criminals are much
better disposed towards the people
they've ransomed and are much more
willing to negotiate
with a native speaking person
thank you I have one more question
so I I know
um arpa funds and I believe there were
monies available
uh maybe this is just for cities and
maybe it was for the state on protection
of water water water and sewer systems
Municipal and I'm sure we have some in
the state
did we receive any of that money for the
state or did that all go to towns and is
I'm sure it's not a capital request was
was there a lot of money that came in
that has been accessed yes
um very good question it isn't it isn't
necessarily in my wheelhouse but I know
uh Bob Scott at DES and his team are
working on that as is our uh our risk
pool manager for the state in
collaboration to you know get
assessments of these water systems and
these other critical infrastructure
systems like you know Dam controllers
and things like that and and then teach
those folks how to mitigate them and
keep them secure going forward so that
there is a ton of activity going on in
that space and there's money being spent
that I believe is Arbor money that
flowed through Des okay thank you anyone
else yes Mike
represent Becker
uh yeah thank you Mr chairman uh the
first question is about the data breach
if somebody is going to take in your
data would you trust them not to you're
going to pay them an interest that
they're not going to release it to
everybody anyway
I couldn't I personally would not okay
very if I have yes please and a
follow-up is uh I just want to mention I
I like the way you summarized uh your
sheet that shows the amounts for the
different
entities that you deal with I think that
makes houses ask a lot less questions
and uh when you give this stuff up front
thank you you're welcome
anyone else
I think now I can safely say thank you
gentlemen for coming all right it's two
more projects but they're pretty
self-explainable so I'm happy to leave
it up leave that or if you'd like me to
quickly explain them I know we're
probably out of time so
um
if it's if it's uh yeah go right ahead
all right so the two others are really
uh it's um
uh to really we doit manages a lot of
Finance we charge back to the agencies
to to fund all of our activities and and
that system's pretty old complex and
inefficient to run and it's not very
transparent to the agencies and to
yourselves and see rep eating nodding
because we've been talking about this
for years so this is a request for us to
kind of
improve our own capabilities and and how
we operate internally from a financial
perspective
um and and really reduce the manual
effort that we spend and then the last
thing is is really around effectiveness
of using the staff all of our staff all
day long are running around helping
people
keep the the business of the State
running
this is about making that more effective
and being able to measure it better so
that we can adjust ourselves if we're
doing badly in a particular place or if
we see a particular thing that's working
really well we can do more of it so
that's my my uh quick summary of those
final two items thank you
thank you
we uh the committee will be in recess
till uh 1 pm time we'll be hearing from
Department administrative services
uh representative Newton asked me what
time a one o'clock meeting starts and it
was uh it was well received by myself so
thank you for that so
um we will
open our uh one o'clock hearing
on my paperwork and a few folks
uh would step forward introduce yourself
we would love to hear
your projects I know we have several
questions and uh
welcome
to Public Works
hi thanks for having us
um I'm Charlie arlinghaus I'm the
commissioner of administrative Services
your presentation and with me are
Karen randomaki director of plant and
property
Ted kupper director of Public Works
so we're going to tag team you this
morning if you don't mind
um so you have a presentation in front
of you and I uh
what I was told in preparation for the
meeting is talk a little bit about about
uh both the process and how we get here
and our role in the ongoing process and
then in addition to that the
meat of the matter which is not very
many slides but is um uh what we what we
got what we're asking for Etc in the
budget process I I want to start and I
thought about this a little bit is
um
you know we have very few opportunities
we have some opportunities not that many
opportunities to kind of talk about how
the process works and some of you are
very very very familiar with it and
other people are very familiar with
pieces of the process and how the
components work what does the governor's
office actually doing what are you guys
doing and why do you have a why do you
have a hearing in June of a of an
election year when you don't even know
it's going to be elected and what's
going on at that and what are the
documents and that and you know what's
in that binder and what's in the other
binder that's on your desk in front of
you and what are all of those things so
what what I want to do is summarize a
little bit
um about what the process is but before
that Karen's going to explain to you who
the department of administrative
Services is and what our role is in
terms of managing
um the infrastructure of the state
government of New Hampshire
great thank you
um so I'm the part of Das that's like
every other agency right we have some
facilities and we're coming to you to
request some capital budget projects so
the division of planned property
maintains and operates 91 buildings
throughout New Hampshire so that's
Office Buildings a lot of which are here
in Concord all the courthouses
throughout the state and what we don't
operate and maintain are residential or
institutional properties so you'll hear
from other agencies such as the Veterans
Home Health and Human Services that
operate those facilities
my division has over 200 staff we cover
things from janitorial so the cleaning
of the facilities maintenance we have a
small security team that makes sure
things don't happen on the weekends when
no one's here grounds crew we have some
skilled trades people Carpenters
electricians plumbers and we have some
office staff that kind of manage the
office side of the business so with a
combination of our in-house staff and
contracted Services it's our goal to
provide safe efficient and accessible
space for state employees and the public
that come into our buildings
foreign
and then Ted's division is Public Works
not to be confused with house Public
Works which is a which is a mistake I
have to make somebody said I'm going
over to Public Works and I thought they
were driving up to Hayes and drive to
see Ted and they were actually coming
over here but Ted will talk to you a
little bit about what the division of
Public Works is
thank you uh the division of Public
Works is essentially a full service
engineering and Architectural office
that provides design and construction
services for building owners and
building managers uh that take care of
state-owned buildings so we either build
new buildings for the state or we
maintain the ones that the state already
owns
um my staff is comprised of Engineers
and architects
many of them licensed
and we service All State agencies and
building managers except the university
system in the community college system
there they take care of their own
buildings on their own
and uh and by law
any project that's over twenty five
thousand dollars is required to go
through DPW to provide consistency in
the design in the construction of the
buildings and to provide a longevity to
those buildings
foreign
I'll point out that both uh both Ted and
Karen are licensed Professional
Engineers
um uh I am not I'm here mostly as um
eye candy I think
um the um or something like that the um
I'm here to so I want to talk about the
the process your slide three of your
slides is a uh is a overview think of it
as a table of contents of the process
and how we start from if you're managing
buildings how you get from managing
buildings to a capital project
appropriated and funded this is not
about normal operations you know fixing
carpeting or or you know standard
ongoing work and we're going to start
Karen's going to talk a little bit from
an agency perspective about things like
facility assessments and then how you
start the capital budget process then
we're gonna we're gonna talk a little
bit about the the form 1as and the big
binder and the hearings and then the
evaluation and the levels of cost
estimation that occur throughout the
process I want to highlight that for you
we regularly hear about how much a
project is likely to cost and the
reliability of that number
ranges from sketchy to pretty good
depending on when in the process
um you're talking about that because at
some very early stage in the process
it's somebody saying to themselves you
know I think we need to completely do do
this over I think it's going to cost
something like four million dollars
and that's not a reliable number four
million is it's usually an educated
estimate but it's not that reliable
later in the process after you know
after Ted's team has gotten through with
it and you know Ted will be at all of
your hearings at some point with giant
binders full of information and
estimates
um for you to rely on but I'm going to
start with from Karen's standpoint uh
managing facilities and where we start
in that process so if you're on slide
four I'll note the only slide with
graphic cartoons on it which is very
exciting
okay so as an agency each year we make
sure that we we have eyes on every
single one of our buildings so my staff
goes around and does a full inventory of
the condition of every system in the
building so it's HVAC it's paint it's
um boilers it's elevator anything that's
in the building we get a condition
assessment on those and we um summarize
those
um so again you'll see a list of kind of
some examples we look at building
envelope we look at the roof the windows
any life safety components whether the
generator is operational
ground so parking lots a lot of times we
have you know cracks that develop and
those become safety issues so all these
little things get tabulated into our
facility assessment
um and then moving on to slide five what
we do with those assessments only uh
every other year when we're building the
capital budget is we
um
we come up with a list of prioritized
projects things that need to be done and
things that are
um that urgently need to be done
um and then as as commissioner
erlinghaus alluded to we've used the
term very rough guesstimate so we come
up with a kind of a ballpark number
where we think that that that project's
going to come in for cost and then
throughout the the 91 facilities that
we're responsible for we look at those
and we prioritize the project so we
might come to you know originally with a
list of 40 Projects which eventually
gets whittled down to what ends up in
the capital budget and that's kind of
how Das as an agency approaches
collecting the data on the facilities
and then coming up with a list of
prioritized capital projects that we
would like to do
so talk about the money I'm going to
mention my my bucket analogy here
because I am addicted to it
um
we came forward with a list once
actually fairly early in my tenure and
and
um
Steve Lorenson who was Karen's
predecessor I didn't mean it was Steve
and Karen and we were talking about
buckets and he said well he said these
are our 12 bucket projects and I said
okay great
um I'm sorry but I'm an idiot I don't
know what that means and he said oh so
it's the 12 buckets not the six buckets
and let me give an example of what that
means when a roof is leaking
and there are 12 places or desks that we
put buckets to catch what leaks out of
them so it doesn't drip onto the
computer we call that a 12 bucket
project
and when there's only six it's a six
bucket project and I thought geez I
should have been able to figure that out
um but what we typically repair at the
state level realistically are the 12
bucket projects we we uh sixes become
twelves eventually but we're often not
able to get to them at the at the three
four five six bucket and when they get
over that so part of that priority is
you know so what are we gonna what are
we gonna do with form 1A for what are we
going to start the process for we're
going to put on our list for this
biennium versus next biennium so let me
let Karen talk a little bit about what a
form 1A is and there's actually a
picture of one which is a nice touch
sure
um so form 1A is the form that every
agency will use to put their the details
down about the capital projects that
they're interested in doing
um so again it's a way to prioritize so
you do a form 1A for each project and
then you put them in a ranked order
According to which your highest priority
project is gives some very general
information about the agency on the
location for where the project is to be
done again we put that very rough
guesstimate number so that's my staff
kind of looking at it and say oh we did
a roof last year and it was about this
many square feet so we think it's going
to be about this many hundreds of
thousands of dollars so it's there's not
a whole lot of s like professional
estimating done at that point it's more
just what we think it's going to cost
and then a brief description of the
project which is really important
because if we're doing a roof then it
might be that we're doing the roof but
we also need to repair like the trim
that's associated with the roof or
um you know maybe there's asbestos that
needs to be removed as we repair the
roof so making sure that we get get that
level of detail into that description as
well and then
again has information on how to get in
touch with the person that developed the
form 1A so that if anyone had questions
on that then that information is
available
um
on the next go ahead slide slide number
seven is is just a a screenshot of an
example of one of those forms so you can
kind of see what I'm talking about
um but what gets submitted is
essentially a packet full of these forms
one for each project that we're that
we're putting forth for consideration so
at that stage
okay
everybody needs a problem
um
oh that's terrible
um so so at this stage of the process so
everybody's doing this around the state
we do a lot
um Karen does a ton of them but so do a
lot of other agencies this is all of
them this binder gets developed it
actually gets developed in in my office
technically these forms are well these
forms are are for the governor
theoretically they're submitted to us we
can buy on them there are binders and
this is this is the thing that is the
beginning of the capital budget hearing
process and so now typically
I don't think Public Works is often
using this book because this is an early
stage of the process I think you're
typically using using a later stage
which we'll get to in a minute
but
um this is the guidebook for the
Governor's capital budget hearing so the
governor's capital budget hearings are
in June or July and and we go from that
there's a governor housing center reps
Etc are on that committee we go through
all the projects in theory everybody
gets a chance to make a pitch Ted is on
the commission I'm on the on the
committee and so is the oit what happens
after that
um
typically what happens is well I'm going
to let Ted talk about the prioritization
we go through typically the governor's
office will say take this and prioritize
it and this is what's happening that
you're not not seeing and not
necessarily part of behind the scenes
and how we get there Ted
so um I'd like to point out that form
1as are typically
uh for deferred maintenance projects on
buildings
um lately the the last few rounds
um there have been some I.T projects
that have been requested and that's
seemed to become a norm
um
the Deferred maintenance in the state on
the buildings is enormous
um you know I think the total of that
binder might be six or seven hundred
million dollars worth of requests
and
um
and usually the capital budget is about
120 125 million so we're taking a chip
at the worst we're doing the 12 bucket
projects not the six bucket projects
right
and
um
and we go through a prioritization
process
so often but not always
um the governor's office asks Das to
create a three-tier priority list for
them and uh and we go through Charlie
myself and the
um assistant director for Public Works
goes through all the requests and
evaluates them with that
severity uh in mind you know how severe
are the are the projects that are being
requested and we put them into three
tiers
um yeah a high priority a medium
priority and a lower priority
and um and we compile that list and we
turn that back over to the governor's
office for his consideration uh we're
not experts on I.T so uh doit does the
same thing for all the doit requests and
provides that list to the governor's
office as well
so so the meat of it to get to you is
the is uh what happens when when the
governor looks at his list I mean
frankly what happens is you know we give
them back this list and governors
typically have said something like do
all the A's and B's or something like
that it's typically about 100 projects
and what they mean by do them
is I want you to take the form 1A I want
you to look at it I want you to have a
one of your engineers or Architects and
they're typically assigned with that
with something in mind about well he did
the women's prison let's give him this
um and they do a much more detailed cost
estimate this is the process by which we
developed the blue book that is that is
in front of you it's typically about a
hundred projects it's typically sent in
September to um to DPW for cost
estimating and that process comes back
in about well talk about how it goes
my estimates so
um
we have this list from the governor's
office where he's asked us to provide an
estimate for all of the selected
projects that that he's Chosen and uh
each project manager so uh you know in
our office our office is filled with
Architects and engineers and there are
commonly referred to as project managers
or construction administrators so each
of the project managers is assigned 7 to
10 of the form 1as the requests
and they take those form 1as and contact
the individual that's at the bottom of
the form 1A
and ask for a meeting
and the purpose of the meeting is to
fully understand what the project is
um the division of Public Works knows
buildings oftentimes
um build building owners or agencies
that use their buildings for some
purpose
don't really understand how buildings
are put together so it's important for
us to interview them and understand
exactly what they want to try to
accomplish with their form 1A
um a scope of work is developed based on
that interview
and then the project manager comes back
to the office and goes through archive
plans
um perhaps goes out to the site and
measures the building for the project
that they want to do in every case each
project is physically inspected by the
project manager then the project manager
comes back and using several different
resources provides an estimate for how
much that project is going to cost
and that estimate includes uh you know
profit and overhead for the contractor
architectural fees that might be
associated with the project
um uh inflation because
we're taking a a con a conceptual
project
that's not going to be built for maybe
three years and we're estimating it
today so
in this example we'd be estimating it in
twenty twenty three dollars but the
project might not be built until 2026 so
we apply an inflation factor to all of
our estimates to bring it to the last
year or the biennium that we hope the
construction might occur
and we go through these you know there's
typically about a hundred projects and
uh and when the project managers have
completed their estimates they're
submitted to myself and Michelle
Giuliano the assistant uh director for
public works and we review each of the
estimates
um oftentimes returning them back to the
project managers with questions that we
have about how they arrived at that
number
and then finally we take a look at the
project description that's provided on
the form 1A and compare that to the
notes that the project managers have
taken about the scope of work for the
project
and we create a narrative that you all
see in the blue book that's in front of
you now
and the narrative is an important part
of this process because when the project
um actually receives an appropriation
and the using agency brings it to us to
go to design and construction
there are some cases where the using
agency might say
um yeah and you know what while we're at
it we want to fix the elevator
but the narrative is only describing a
roofing project
and it's in the narrative is important
because the appropriation is
specifically for that description
and we have to evaluate what the using
agency wants to do with the money
compared to the description and
sometimes we have to tell them well you
can't do your elevator with this
appropriation it's only for the roof
and and these are all completed sometime
around the end of November
so that's so that's this book and Ted
will explain to you and I know this is
remedial for some of you but there's
some points I want to want to hit in the
process the narrative in this book is
not just a couple of words somebody
jotted down on a piece of paper and
that's the point that uh their agencies
routinely and we're often that agency
who want to do something else with the
money because you're looking and you're
going you know what it turns out can we
also do this this came in under bid well
underestimate that's actually not common
lately
um and uh we want to do that and I think
that that both the LBA the legislature
broadly
um and and we look at this to say this
is the intent of the appropriation if if
it's within the narrative here this is
what we're using it's not the title it's
not the words on the page it's it's the
intent and we regard this as the intent
unless there's some evidence that in the
committee deliberations the committee
said yeah do that but also you do don't
just do perimeter security and fence
detection like throw in the sewer with
with that as well in which case we would
allow that otherwise they have to get
new legislation or go through all sorts
of machinations so so that's this and I
only say that to say somebody said to me
once well they're limited to this and
what can go in the capital budget right
and I and and what I said is uh first of
all I'm not about to tell the
legislature they're limited to anything
but secondly no they can do anything
they want stuff can come up later or
everything else
traditionally
this is where 98 of the capital budget
comes from but it doesn't have to it
just happens to be the stuff where we
have better estimates more detailed work
there are other things those estimates
are going to be a little dice here oh
and that's that book is used by the
governor's office to produce this
which is in green again this year
um I guess they like green
um but and then that traditionally is
introduced as you know is House Bill 25.
although I suppose not always I'm sure
there's a year it wasn't but I don't
know when that was
um in the legislative phase what did we
do to help you well first of all we will
do anything you want at any time in the
process we're happy to that's what we're
we exist as a resource but for the most
part Ted is here and Ted is meant to be
here hanging out with giant canvas bags
full of estimates because this isn't an
estimate this isn't the estimate they
did There's you know two to six pages
worth of actual going through and and
calculating things and he's there as a
resource in case you in case you want to
go well what's with the acquire building
a 25 Hall Street what does that include
and what did you look at and what did
you include in that and he's there so
he's meant to be there for you
that's the process and I'm gonna put a
pin in that unless anybody wants to ask
a question about that
and then do an ask for us
yes I've been just wondering in terms of
coming up with these estimates
um granted inflation has been going on
but with what is the covid situation how
does it that affect the estimate well
the the the you know supply chain issues
and and related issues I mean there are
a bunch of things that are affecting
what we're paying for stuff right now
and our our estimates are meant to be
derived from what what's actually
happening out in the field you know we
know from bids that come in on a regular
basis what's going on with cost of
materials what's going on with cost of
Labor I would say the things that that
drive you know timing is an issue with
the ability to get major pieces of
equipment
um labor shortages is an issue and
that's particularly true on things like
second shift
um if you're doing second shift work
it's harder to get second shift workers
people tend people tend to have enough
enough trouble getting first shift
workers so these things all factor in
what we're what we're meant to be doing
what we try to do is to look at our
experience in estimates it's easy to say
you know it should cost about 400 a
square foot to to build a that might be
the wrong number to build a new building
it's another thing to say yeah but the
last time we built in built a new
building which actually doesn't happen a
lot but it cost like 550 a square foot
because of this this and this and so
we're constantly updating that and and I
would say that
estimating construction is a really I
don't want to say it's a crap shoot but
there's a lot going on in that if you
get a lot of bids and a lot of people
know they're bidding we get lower prices
if some company knows he's the only guy
bidding
um we're not going to get that great a
deal and if it happens to be something
that's particularly complicated that
nobody wants to do or is in a
particularly
difficult location
that affects those things as well
there's just a lot that goes into it
unfortunately
to that
so the estimates that we've been talking
about this morning to you
um
are are the best shot today at what we
think the construction might be about
three years from now and that's what
goes in the blue book and that's for the
purpose of an appropriation
when the using agency brings a project
to us
and we begin the design phase at several
points in the design phase we actually
have our consultant prepare an estimate
so that we know two things one
um are are we designing something that
we can afford you know via the
appropriation and the other is
um to alert us to the fact that yes
we're designing what we're supposed to
but it looks like it's going to cost us
more
so
um in most cases when we go to bid with
our projects
we will not go to bid if the estimate
that we have is severely over the
appropriation that's that's been
allotted for that particular project
that can be a big issue and it's
unfortunately there's a lot of that
um
in the absence of other questions which
I don't want to discourage oh hi
thank you
Mr chairman thank you
um just out of curiosity uh
you have a project that starts at a six
bucket and we know that's going to be
put on hold
for a while then it finally elevates
itself to a 12 bucket which might mean
it might get on to the list
and then three years from now
that 12 bucket project
is probably a 18 to 24 bucket project
yeah
which now quadruples the price of that
project if my educated guess would be
well
yeah
um
at the end of the day it's the the giant
challenge with
um
with maintenance the state has a very
large and complex system of buildings
and whatnot related to it that are in
varying degrees of repair
um they're not new there's a lot of work
that needs to be done we did a deferred
maintenance at some point during one of
the arpa things somebody in the in the
legislature came and said can you do a
deferred maintenance list for us and I
worked with Karen on something and
worked with Karen I called Karen and
said can you do it deferred maintenance
list that's how I worked with her but um
she's doing a list and said what how
deep do you want to go
and I said do something that's about 250
million because
now it's the first 250 million but it's
always that question about am I you know
we could do a deferred maintenance list
that's about I don't know a billion
dollars if we wanted to and we could do
a comprehensive evaluation of every
building which we're looking at doing
anyway that could get you what's the
lifespan of everything but what we do is
we we know that you know the state
doesn't have the capacity to to repair
as much as you might if you had had the
money so the idea is to is to triage
like anything else you do and you look
at it and say
can this weight you know is this part of
it is what's the need today is this
Dreadful today maybe maybe not but it's
going to be Dreadful in two years is
this something where we can we can you
know rebuild something
and um and it'll be okay for six to
eight years and and and where do you get
there I mean people are familiar for
example with the parking garage where
you know every every two years you know
we throw a little bit of money at it and
it and it lasts for a little bit longer
and it's like that used car you had
you've got a 73 Nova where you uh had a
73 Nova and um it's a very heavy car and
safe but um I got eight miles to the
gallon and uh but you routinely you're
like okay the muffler and like well I
don't mind the noise I'm not going to do
the muffler I'm going to do the right
rear tire because it's worse than the
left rear tire and you just you like can
I get another two years out of this or
do I need to make a bigger investment
and so every day we're making decisions
like that and Karen has an enormous team
of people it's not really enormous is it
it's Karen is a team of people
um who work on this every day who are
sort of walking to buildings and looking
around and and
all of you at some point have had a
meeting I'm sure in some State office
where you you
um I'm looking at the chairman because I
think we had one where he was appalled
at the room I had him in
um because it was kind of a it's the
room I have almost every meeting I have
in just for the record but it it could
use a little work
and so uh you do the best you can
that make sense
and for Mr Arling I'll say a little bit
of work is a is an exaggeration I hope
you still don't have that Nova but we do
need to get to that room yeah do you
have more presentation before we take
questions because the only the only
thing left was I'm going to tell you
about our projects uh what we got and
what we're gonna ask for but you want to
do that first please okay
um Karen's going to do that
great so I'm on slide 15 which has um
the projects that are in the governor's
capital budget
um so I'll just go through those and
just give a little overview Courthouse
generators so we have five remaining
courthouses that could use emergency
generation and we prioritized
um the ones that were in the uh most
remote or severe weather climates first
so those ones um are currently underway
but there's five more that could use an
emergency generator for for power outage
situations so that's the first project
on the list the Rochester courthouse is
new construction so there's a design
design was approved in the last budget
and that design is happening now this
would be the money to construct that new
courthouse
um project number three the Emergency
Operations Center mechanical
Replacements and repairs so the EOC is a
24 7 operation
um critical you know to the needs of the
State of New Hampshire here and there's
a few mechanical things that need to be
replaced over there including some water
tanks so that is a high priority on the
list
there building which houses Health and
Human Services office staff
has very few heating zones so it's a
large large building and if you turn the
heat on it's on and if you turn it off
it's off and it makes for an energy
inefficient building as well as an
uncomfortable building to be in so we're
looking to add some more zones to the
heating system over there and then
finally
um
everybody we request money for the
Statewide emergency fund and that's a
fund that's managed in my office
available to All State agencies that
have state-owned property and that is
available for things that are unforeseen
so if you have I think we had a rest
area that got struck by lightning and
had some electrical repairs that needed
to be done and that agency wasn't able
to cover that in their operating budget
so they come to me and they ask for
money from the Statewide emergency fund
to cover those costs and so we've
provided funding for I think All State
agencies at at one point or another to
cover some sort of unforeseen event that
caused damage to a facility
um the next slide which I think is the
last slide
um
just wanted to take the opportunity to
talk about some operational challenges
and additional needs that we have so
again the the form 1as that were done uh
a year ago I think had about 40 or 45
projects for the Department of
administrative Services we saw the five
on the last slide that were that made it
into the governor's phase a couple other
things for consideration one of the the
kind of critical projects that was cut
late in the process was replacement of
some chillers at 29 Hazen which is where
some critical State Labs are housed
um
that's a four to six million dollar
replacement for those Chillers
um we've been talking in-house and and
decided a better way to address that
issue is to rebuild the chillers and get
as Charlie mentioned maybe another five
to eight years out of the equipment
um which I think is a good cost
investment and that would be closer to
300 000 that we'd be looking to cover
the cost of that
um we're in the process or getting ready
to go out to bid for phase one of the
State House Annex renovation project
um which would be a full renovation
including adding HVAC to a building that
doesn't currently have it
um making better use of the space and
making it overall just a better place to
come to work too
um so funding for the next phase of that
project was an original Quest request at
4.3 million
and then finally something that's been
neglected over the past five or so years
is Paving so
um as many of you probably know if you
don't keep up with Paving it just
continues to deteriorate and get worse
so we're kind of behind schedule on
keeping up with our Paving of parking
lots and our roadways that we manage so
we manage roadways on like the New
Hampshire Hospital campus and up on
Hayes and drive
so just to kind of cover some of you
know to catch us up to where we should
be
um you know requesting a three million
dollars to do some of that Paving work
that needs to be done
foreign
that's it
so if so this last page here operational
challenge additional needs
in the event that money could be found
this is the priority and the numbers
that of projects you'd like to proceed
with
okay yes
could I um ask you I'll ask you a few
questions if I could
so for the new members can you explain
about the New Hampshire hospital
complex
what what it is and other than Health
and Human Services who's occupying that
sure please so the Pleasant Street
campus which is sometimes called Sops or
the State Office Park South or the
gallon I think it is Office Park
is on Pleasant Street kind of near
Concord High School and all that all the
old buildings are used currently by the
state for government there's a newer
building it's the mid 80s but
um I'm old enough that that counts as
new which is the actual New Hampshire
hospital the acute psychiatric facility
or APS there's an S there I don't know
what it is
um
the old buildings were slowly repurposed
and their repurposed originally
according to a to a plan that was
developed I want to say in the late 90s
early 2000s uh representative uh kalawa
from Litchfield I think was very
instrumental in that and we looked at
buildings and and people might remember
if you've been around long enough that
like the Walker building which is one of
our nicer buildings was going to be
there's a capital budget appropriation
to tear it down
um I think we got money to tear down
before my time but
um and um and a woman who's later a
State Rep on City councilor in Concord
Kathy Rogers who passed away recently I
think chained herself to a tree and to
stop that from happening it's actually a
lovely building I remember from when I
was first married I would say to my wife
this is the stupid thing people do they
want to tear down this this pretty
building and well we didn't and so part
of that was we developed a plan for that
over time they've developed into offices
a lot of the buildings are occupied by
HHS for their various space there's a
big building on the hill called the main
building which is mostly HHS and maybe
50 000 square feet of Corrections for a
lot of their offices
uh Thayer which is as you turn in the
first drive was the building right in
front of you
um is I think entirely HHS behind Thayer
is Spalding which is labor I'm going to
get some of this wrong but I'm going to
try behind Spalding is laundergan which
was education although if we end up
buying Hull Street they would they would
move there and that building which is
one of our
um worst buildings in terms of needs
would be renovated next to londergan is
dra which is all sometimes called
medical and surgical but that's where
dra is in their offices it's the old
medical and surgical building which is
why they say there are ghosts in the
basement
um
in front of that is Johnson stop me if I
get something wrong
um in front of that is Johnson which has
Board of tax and land appeals and a
couple of other things uh housing
appeals board used to have the
governor's office of energy and planning
which doesn't exist anymore
um I think it has a child advocate is in
there as well so in a couple of small
entities
just beyond that is dollar which has a
sort of a some some frosted glass on the
front of it you'll know it in that way
mostly HHS I think there's a talking
books thing in there and there are a
couple of other smaller entities some of
which are states some of which aren't
um up from that is the Brown building
which is hhs's headquarters and has a
parking garage attached to it it's
behind the main building if you will
next to that I believe is Thayer
no it's the old Toby school I take that
back the old Toby school which is
Employment Security one of the more
recently renovated buildings and it's
quite lovely it just shows you what
federal funds can do next to that uh
sort of next to that and on the one
corner the corner of fruit and pleasant
is the Walker building which has
Insurance on one end you said the puc on
the other now it's the department of
energy and what and the residual puc
that exists there I think Voc Rehab from
the Department of Education and the
disability determination unit of the
Department of Education is there as well
and
um
I'm sure there's somebody and Associate
entities like the child at the consumer
advocate for them in site selection so
that's most of that building some of the
buildings on that campus which we don't
manage if people stay in a building we
don't manage it you know so Corrections
we don't manage any corrections
buildings but transitional housing so
some of the things that look like houses
are mostly transitional housing and it's
people I think I'll get this right
who've left the hospital like they're
not
um in the psychiatric hospital anymore
and they're theoretically transitioning
to the community and that exists there
there's a building also there that's
like a gym called Howard Rec which they
use for some things and I think that's
most of the buildings
oh records and archives
and Phil Brook right so records and
archives is also there at Secretary of
State's records and archives which you
know we've expanded a couple times I
think it might actually technically be
called the Leon Anderson building
um but I think we've expanded it uh
twice and it fills up very fast because
we generate a lot of stuff as a state
and then on the other Corner which would
be I think Clinton and fruit is Phil
Brook which was part of the uh state
hospital then it wasn't for a while and
we had a couple of entities there like
oplc and then it is again because they
needed it was the easiest building to
renovate back into patient space I don't
know exactly who's there as opposed to
in the hospital itself on the edge of
the campus on Clinton Street looks like
it's carved out of the campus but we
don't always consider it part of the
campus is the Concord uh District Court
Circuit Court District Court District
Court and so that's that's on Clinton
Street kind of at the one kind of where
Bo Brook crosses Clinton Street and I
think that's all of them that's a lot of
the State offices and and when the plans
were originally done they're still in
there's still an old master plan which
probably could be updated but um dating
back to about 04 and and it envisions
moving people out of rented space into
space there which we did a lot of over
over the
um Double O's if you will
thank you Charlie I was just going to
ask you for a map of those locations but
that was a great dissertation we can we
can get you a map yeah if you could they
uh so Lonergan which brings me to 25
Hall Street
so in the last capital budget we
appropriated a amount of money I think
we were fixing a
toilets bathrooms were so bad they were
embarrassed to have people in the
education building and then I think we
added more on to that how much of that
was completed
and
who is who
whom do you see then going into that
space or what's the schedule to renovate
that space because I was here back when
that was 2005 era we were looking to
move from outside to inside that we
would recoup that space let me let me
have Karen talk a little bit about where
we are on things like the elevators and
the bathrooms and Asbestos and then I'll
talk a little bit about the broader
space planning issues we have okay
sure so
um this started as an abatement project
um the entire building has been abated
of asbestos
um other than things that might be like
behind walls that we're not going to
open up uh just for the sake of getting
asbestos out of it
um so it was abated
um we did design a project for the
elevator and bathrooms and the
restoration of the ceilings that had to
be removed because the ceilings had
asbestos in it that went out to bid
um when the bids came back we didn't
have enough funding to complete the
project so it kind of got tabled
um for now we have some arpa funding in
our deferred maintenance that we'd like
to do some additional work to launder
again and so what we decided to do was
keep the design for the original
components that was done incorporate
that into a larger project and bid it
out all as one big project so that will
be coming out later this spring we'll be
bidding that out again as a as a more
com comprehensive renovation roughly how
long do we think it'll take
um we're thinking once a bit once the
the boots at the ground so to speak
it'll be about a 12-month uh renovation
project and how much how much space
ballpark square footage or how many
offices were there yeah so laundry
again's about 50 000 square feet
um it is all little tiny not little tiny
but all individual offices so to speak
and that's just the way that it was
built because it was an old dormitory
um and based on our initial look at
things it's going to remain that way
because of structural components that
are in the walls and so it will be a lot
of individual office space but we're
looking to like widen the doorways
doorways are not up to code right now
there's no HVAC in there so we're
looking to bring it up to a more modern
space thank you
um the the question about who goes where
is a it's a uh is a good question and
it's also um you know we think about it
long term with a building I didn't name
which is Bancroft which is sort of next
to the main building and and what they
call Annex one on that campus which is
which is lovely from the outside and
we've stabilized their money in one of
the capital budgets recently to
stabilize it
um and it has a lot of touches inside
but it's not occupiable now but what
would what would go in there is one of
the questions
um there are a bunch of things that are
happening right so the one is the whole
notion of granite place and the the old
Lincoln Financial building where doj is
going to move and who else can go in
there
um there are about five or six other
components that are happening
um
you know Corrections it doesn't like
their their current space in the main
building partly because the main
building is e
um but partly because they're not
connected to each other there are
various components
um there's a building on South Street
um sort of toward if anyone knows where
Tucker's is the restaurant it's sort of
toward there
um it's actually the old New Hampshire
Memorial Hospital and um
um doit had had a piece of it and his
little tiny piece of HHS and there's a
discussion about what to do with that we
look at these spaces and we think with
it with the annex renovation at least
part of it even though the initial
phases of that renovation are broadly
mechanical and a lot of the
infrastructure because that's where you
have to start
um there's going to be a lot of moving
pieces that go there you know does
agriculture move to Granite place maybe
maybe not where does Corrections go
where does doit who has a unit that was
in South Street but they want to move
out and they're going to start hoteling
a little bit
using fewer desks because of remote work
where they're better suited to and so
we're going to do all of those in
addition there's a couple of small
agencies that are might have like Human
Rights Commission for example has to get
out of their space by October hmm I
don't know where everybody's going I I
will tell you this that we have a we
have a meeting on our schedule I think
Karen and Cassie and I next week
maybe Friday I don't know next week
probably
um it was supposed to be yesterday but
it got moved
um and one of the things we're doing is
looking at the giant jigsaw puzzle but
it's a giant jigsaw puzzle
that's not really that helpful is it uh
well it's a start and thank you so when
I when I look and see that you know we
have we have the courthouse so again
that building what are we going to do
with that Old Courthouse do we retain
that space we own that space
so what's going to happen with that so
like Rochester do you know the Rochester
so the city approached us on that and
they are interested in the building they
would like the building for City
operations in exchange there they want
to work something out to give us some
land where we can build this the new
proposed Courthouse
we do have some language that I believe
Senator gray drafted up
um
to possibly you know facilitate that
transfer of property
can you also I'm telling us can you
speak of the
there's nowhere there's a lot of
projects outside of here that have been
funded through arpa funds or cash that
was turned could you talk to us about
that
uh maybe it's the short answer
um we could shut the camera off if we
could no no no
um we um
so uh someone so the short version I
don't know everything that was
appropriate with our Pro we think we do
and we think we know you know if they
end up if they end up um Waltzing
through Ted we know what we know what a
lot of those are and and of course it's
been an issue right the last three
budgets if we count this one have had
significant House Bill 2 Appropriations
that are quasi-capital and it's not
something that existed before I think
representative evil has a amendment to
uh to another bill that would actually
change the name of the capital
budget overview Community a couple of
projects overview committee and I said
well I think that makes sense because we
used to think of all of that stuff as
happening in the capital budget and it
doesn't I can tell you what we're doing
with we have two we have an HVAC
um our appropriation of something like
18 or 20 million dollars
um and uh and I can tell you what's
what's in that we have a deferred
maintenance one and I can tell you
what's in that I can give you a list
thank you I know Parks has one too or
dncr I should say has one as well which
is wide ranging in terms of capital like
Construction
I'm not too sure about many others
if we could see a list at another time
you know what I'll do I'll ask you why
don't I ask Ted at a start so I'll give
you ours let me ask Ted to put together
a list of projects that are at public
works so to speak that are not funded
for the capital budget
yeah so we'll start with that and we'll
get you a list and my last question
before I turn it over to the committee
is
um the emergency uh fund which is in
here for what's it 1.5 million dollars
or something could you uh send to us
over the course of the last three or
four years how much of that it's very
important I'm not saying it's not but if
you could just if you could just tell us
what's actually been expended what was
appropriate and what was expended that
that would be helpful other questions
from the committee I'll start with
represent Connor
did you guys ever thank you uh Mr
chairman
um I just want to know what a what is a
chiller
oh a chiller yes it's like air
conditioning but do you wanna do you
want to get yeah more detail it's a
component of the central HVAC system
that you know sits outside it makes cold
water that then circulates through the
building okay thank you
if I can I got a couple
um commissioner you've got a requests in
here for the next phase of the annex and
when you hit 50 you have to become ADA
Compliant and I guess my question is why
haven't we become ADA Compliant earlier
it's embarrassing and horrible that it
hasn't been done it should have been
done yesterday can you tell me how we're
going to have it done tomorrow
we're um what we what we do with with
Adas we work very closely with the
governor's Commission on disability was
an ADA coordinator although I think that
position is is open right now or that's
not that's not her title but what it is
and and when we do any construction
project
um
that's a significant component of it is
that is that we take any building that
exists today and make it uh make it ADA
Compliant and fix the things that aren't
fixed and I'm going to use two examples
of that that
um you know laundry and for example the
the this discussion of the bathrooms and
whether they're ADA Compliant or not
when when a significant
um uh when significant work on them was
done in the 90s I think they were made
ADA Compliant within the terms of the
law at the time because nothing's been
done since then no additional work was
done are they great no
um but that's why we're fixing them with
the annex you know one of the questions
is right now the Ada access to the
annexes is that there's a door that used
to be the division of personnel that's
um street level on School Street used to
be the state police too if you're
keeping score
um and um and that's the that's the ADA
compliance we had a discussion about
whether that's an appropriate
appropriate or not and the problem is
it's a little too much separate but
equal and it's a little too Plessy and
not enough Brown if you know
um and uh so we're doing something
significant and when are we doing it in
the process phase one not phase two not
phase three but we're doing it right up
front that's actually I think literally
the first thing we're doing we're
putting a lift in in essentially in the
front of the building
are what we do with every building is
that because
um the significant changes that you make
you want to make when you're when you're
doing something else in addition to that
there's a there's a sort of an easier
enforcement mechanism it's very easy to
say to an agency doing work you got to
do this and so it's it's uh it's a it is
a significant priority of every new
construction that we do oops and if I
can follow up
um
you've you've gone through a whole
process of of uh Round Rob and where
everybody has to go for office space and
it's always revolving and changing and
then you mentioned the annex and you're
doing the construction and trying to
figure out who's going to do what or
where or whatever
and it just seems a little backwards to
me that
you'd figure that out before you do any
renovation
and you can plan your renovation from
that perspective and I guess what I'm
asking is you're looking for some money
there's already money on the table
is there a detailed plan that we can see
of what you're trying to do and what
it's going to become because I hear
rumors that part of the upstairs already
looks like a layout from Amazon or Ebay
and that
um
government does need privacy and
security government does need offices
you have to be able to cop discuss
Personnel plans you have to entertain
people like us and explain stuff when
we're stupid
and two conference rooms here or for the
building doesn't seem to make can we see
a detailed plan yes absolutely I I could
I could show you anytime time and I can
bring for the committee um the the
detailed layouts
um
they won't necessarily be 100 bidable
documents but in terms of floor plans
and things like that you can see what's
happening
um I know what you're referring to
there's a there's a in one corner of the
fourth floor we did of the annex we did
um
we did asbestos remediation at the end
of 2021 there was money in the
maintenance budget because of covet
frankly and we tore down some walls it
happened to be that that group which was
the computer group was out of the
building at the time we got rid of a lot
of walls it's very wide open space not
everybody likes that not everybody likes
to work in a cubicle
um it's not where we're going to be in
the end the number of individual offices
in the annex when the renovation is done
will be the same number I think give or
take two
um as it exists today
what will exist there will be more
conference rooms and more additional
private space for example space for
making phone calls but space for
meetings with small groups and large
groups and it'll just be more functional
but I'm happy to show you plans and
realistically anytime we're building
anything there's no reason anybody on
the committee can't um can't see those
plans or you know walk through them one
of the things I'd like to you know
probably you're not going to want to do
it in this phase of your deliberations
but we'd love to walk you through some
of the buildings and we could even go
through the tunnels at the hospital
campus if you wanted some people like
that some people are spooked out
now I I appreciate that and we will work
with you to make that happen great um
yes representative Newton yes thank you
could you briefly explain
the procedure uh and specific Rochester
Courthouse
the Old Courthouse
when they say when the state gets a
building that they no longer
have use for I guess if that's what we
would call it or how you'd put it is
there a bidding process does the state
say we need to see if the state needs it
first
then do offer to the city then you offer
to bidding or is the city part of the
bidding process after I think in this
case
I'm a little confused because for the
city to get the design funding they had
to provide land for the new courthouse
and that was done and now you're saying
from what I heard that they might get
the Old Courthouse and trade for the
land that they had to buy to get the
design
to move forward with the design and we
did spend as a state we spent several a
few hundred thousand dollars just
recently to upgrade the HVAC system and
stuff in the Old Courthouse so I guess
how do you guarantee to the taxpayer
that the state is getting the best bang
for the black for the taxpayer when
something like this takes place let me
let me let Karen talk a little bit about
about
um Rochester right uh in a second and as
you know courts are courts have a
slightly different governing mechanism
because there's a court accreditation
committee that that meets an over and
oversees things as well but let me add
something about Surplus property the
state does not dispose of surplus
property
um without offering it to other people
are there occasional exceptions to that
when we do something like a swap like a
land swap but there are significant
approvals required for that there are
it's a fairly complicated process that
involves long range for example it
involves historical resources and I
think most of the time court is involved
I don't want to say every single time
but there are a whole bunch of different
Hoops that have to be jumped through
before the state ever relinquishes any
property of any sort that would all have
to happen
in terms of Rochester I think it's been
a sort of Cooperative process with the
city from early on and and we do want to
ensure that that the state gets what it
needs while being accommodating to our
neighbors as well but Karen can talk a
little bit about about where we are in
that process sure the um the
appropriation from 2021 for the design
required us to come forward with a piece
of land that would be viable for
construction so we did that it still
owned that piece of land is still owned
by the city
they're willing to you know allow us to
use that property to build the
courthouse you know in exchange for the
building but it we came forward saying
in in public works did the study to show
that yes that's a buildable piece of
land it could fit the size building that
we're thinking of constructing it could
be cited here there's room for parking
all those questions were answered we
brought that to the capital budget
overview committee for then approval to
move forward with the design so we're we
haven't gotten to the point yet the
Project's not funded for construction as
you know and so we haven't acquired
actually acquired the land yet it's just
a viable piece of land
uh just a quick follow-up is anywhere in
the process is there um
estimates of value so it's kind of like
ten dollars for ten dollars is that is
that considered what the the value of
something is both the land and or the
building as it exists
yeah as as part of the both the
acquisition and the disposal of property
we would we would have to present to uh
depending on who's doing the appropriate
body
um estimates of costs and appraisals and
and whatnot and all of those kind of
things we don't just kind of go yeah I
think it's okay
any further questions Mr chairman yes
question yes thank you my question is
about vehicle charging station I want to
ask you because you're the custodian the
State Building because otherwise I was
thinking of asking every state agency
have any charging stations for either
state employees vehicles have been put
in or any anticipated in the next few
years because of that reason my
background this is might be good for
employee Recruitment and Retention
because the private sector is beginning
to install these charging stations as a
way to keep attract and keep employees I
don't know if the state's thought of
this and maybe even if there'd be a
small charge you know it could recoup
some of the costs so I don't know if you
thought about this and where this is
going on now thanks so for example
there's a it's a it's a significant
discussion point about the um uh the
legislative parking garage that
um is content that might be built or
what I don't know what I'm supposed to
say
um and uh leaving aside that giant Tesla
banks at every liquor store that seemed
to exist we have some behind the boiler
house here and I know Karen some
yeah so there there's a Federal grant
that Des
um applied for on behalf of several
State facilities including I believe
Walker building and some up at Hazen
drive those have not been installed yet
I think there's still some question
about because of the federal funding
aspect whether there's made in America
components and how to acquire something
that's made in America when there is
nothing that's made in America so we're
struggling a little bit there but we
have been
um
including in any big major renovation
where you're you're disrupting the
ground anyway putting in conduits
putting in the infrastructure as it's
much much less expensive to do that at
the time when you're already Excavating
in preparation of down the road if we
you know were to need to add those so I
think the the short answer is that we
don't have a lot yet but that we're
definitely thinking about it and making
plans to incorporate it in future
projects yes so that was what was done
at the the Green Street Boiler House
here downtown
um we knew kind of knew ahead of time
that we were going to be Excavating the
property and that it would make sense to
put the conduit in and then later on We
did an RFP where a third party company
came in and installed the Chargers they
own the Chargers they manage the
Chargers you pay with a credit card or a
an app I guess you can get and then we
get reimbursed for the electricity
component because that's a state expense
but the company kind of manages the
entire program
chairman is this for in just employees
or the public or both so at the Boiler
House I believe the spaces are
um you know during the day they're for
the legislature to use at night it
becomes available for for anyone that's
parking downtown to use and in which
case they would you know they do need to
use a credit card or the app to to pay
for the charging
thank you very much
thank you uh we're running a little late
any further questions
um one one more item and you can get
back to me on it over at the hospital
campus if you can give me an update
where we are with and maybe it's already
been completely remediated the old Power
Plant
I can just give you you know very quick
kind of update so that project was split
into two phases phase one was basically
to get the building down and that was
done
um you know about a year ago I think
phase two is underway now and that's
kind of restoring and supporting the
retaining wall to make sure that the
property is stable and and looks
somewhat nice
um until we decide you know what we're
going to put on it long term thank you
yucky stuff all the yucky stuff is gone
all right thank you and thank you for
your time and uh we will follow up with
you on the tour thank you
foreign
up our 2PM hearing a little tardy at 207
community college system of New
Hampshire
and gentlemen if you would um
tell us who you are and we will go
through our presentation and before we
do
welcome to Public Works
thank you very much sir Mark Rubinstein
Chancellor for the community college
system of New Hampshire
I'm Matthew Moore the director of
capital planning and development and
behind us we have Shannon Reed and Scott
Fields a CFO
please take us through
I don't think there's much but please
take us through okay I appreciate that
and first couple of slides our
background I hope that folks are
familiar with our work seven colleges
across the state serving each of the
regions programs that serve about 21 000
students a year from high school
Workforce and in college programs that
lead to careers and transfer
opportunities
on slide three key priorities for us
responding to the needs of New Hampshire
families for high quality affordable
post-secondary education strengthening
New Hampshire's Workforce and increasing
the value and the utility of our
campuses for the communities that they
serve
on slide four just a brief note that
these align with commissioner caswell's
strategic plan New Hampshire's economic
recovery and expansion strategy our
programs align with key industries of
the state and our efforts are to be a
good partner for those Employers in
those Industries throughout New
Hampshire
foreign
moving to slide five
Governor's capital budget and zero
appropriation for Capital I'm going to
say that that's on me I had a
conversation with the governor and with
Mr Scully a while back in preparation
for budget and he asked about capital
and I said to him that I I needed a
little more time we need to think about
this as you'll see the second light of
that slide last March we had submitted
about 19 million dollars in projects
and what I said is that in the last year
that I've spent with the colleges and
become quite begun to question whether
or not we've really figured out fully
what we should be doing with some of
those facilities more of our work is
online the utilization of that space is
not currently optimal and I'm not yet
sure that we've got all of that mapped
out so what I intended to say was I
think we need a little more time for
some of those projects I didn't expect
that this would turn into a zero
appropriation particularly because there
are some projects that I think are ready
to move forward and some ongoing
critical needs for buildings and also
for I.T
um if you'll move on please to slide
seven
the grid this is an outline you're going
to see a lot of things here there are
roofs and rtus
windows and things that are Life Safety
basic mechanics of making sure these
buildings are still functional that we
continue to be good stewards of the
buildings that we have and that we're
going to continue to use also see some
requests specific to it Hardware that's
end of life and and
some life cycle replacement needs that
we have
on slide 8 the one specific Capital
project and respiratory therapy
laboratory this is a need Statewide has
been identified in the southern part of
the state our River Valley Community
College has a respiratory therapy
program and the opportunity here is to
repurpose space in Nashua make it usable
for respiratory therapy program that can
serve that quarter of the state
we already have a model where River
Valley has developed an LPN program
which is now made available through four
other colleges under a single
accreditation it's the same approach
we'd propose to take so the opportunity
to get this program up and running
quickly and to begin to produce more
respiratory therapists for the southern
part of the state is is a fairly
efficient one we believe
and uh stop there and see if I've got
any questions yet
thank you I'll I'll start and then we'll
fill in so
if I if I were to look at your list that
you presented
uh critical maintenance your slide
number seven yes sir and I were to look
at that are your are those prioritized
with what's most important to you
yes okay so the man the Manchester first
three Manchester projects are are your
highest priority
okay bring me to
bring me now to this program the
respiratory therapy labs
are there would you be or do you partner
with some other person when you do that
like you did with so many of your others
whether it was Automotive is that
Standalone and how many how many if you
were to get that program how many jobs
do you think you'd create
well the state of New Hampshire
currently has 400 respiratory therapists
by 2030 our economic and labor market
folks tell us we'll need almost 500
roughly 30 a year prepared and currently
our River Valley program produces about
a dozen graduates we think we can
roughly double that in the next couple
of years essentially meet the state's
ongoing need for delivering that that
occupational certification
in that this would be your number one
thing on this programming side that you
would like to see happen correct okay
thank you questions from others
yes please representative thank you Chad
so
a new program you're going to develop in
at the NCC is that have you gotten
requests from the hospitals in Nashua
and nearby yes and I've had
conversations
um and most recently happened to be at
uh CMC respiratory therapy is one of the
areas that they recognize the growing
need for the population that they serve
and that we serve thank you thanks for
being here today thank you
while I have you here how how is the LPN
program coming because there is such a
shortage as there is everywhere are
people enrolling in it or they're not
enrolling it is it time to try something
else that program is terrific
last year 37 graduates and degrees
conferred and this year already 37 this
year 53 already conferred and that was
just with one location offering the
program we're now at four and we'll have
five shortly the ability to scale that
program by 24 we'll be preparing roughly
a hundred graduates a year from that
program roughly half of the annual
demand for LPNs in the state's Workforce
but it's also because of the way that
program is structured it's a 12-month
program but It prepares students who are
interested that they can step into the
second year of an RN program if they
want to continue so and there are some
constraints on these programs because of
clinical placements and in in some ways
if you lose a student in the first year
of an R A two-year RN program you've got
a you've got a gap it's like flying a
plane with an empty seat with the LPN
program we can fill those spaces with
interested students who complete the
one-year program so it makes both that
program successful but also makes our RN
programs that much more successful
on track again this year for probably
between those two programs close to 300
nursing degrees to be conferred by the
community college system seven colleges
thank you one of the um one of the
Hallmarks that I always hold out with
why money sometimes is better spent at
your level than up at that larger
Institution
is the the tremendous number of uh
graduates that stay in our state work in
our state have families and contribute
with that with that surge in LPNs can
you tell me that many of those are
staying in our own state or where the
demand's so high everywhere else are
leaving us I I did reach out last week
to New Hampshire influence security one
of the pieces of information we're
trying to get is better tracking on
where our graduates are we know that 93
percent of our students are from New
Hampshire and a significant number who
are not from New Hampshire in the Upper
Valley you know they're on the Vermont
border and there's almost a permeability
in terms of Workforce there North North
Country on the side with Maine so I
would say that the vast majority are
here now I can't tell you that we don't
have some students who migrate south
because the wages in Massachusetts are
compelling but majority of our students
in fact two-thirds of our nursing
degrees are conferred to students who
are 25 and older these are students who
already have lives in this community
don't necessarily want to be commuters
particularly if they've got families
that make an hour and a half commute to
Boston area and not a good proposition
so I'm reasonably confident even without
having access to perfect data that the
majority of our students are here and
they're staying here and they're working
here
thank you all for that other questions
thank you thank you
um
Matt do you want to take through that
I would also like to request uh and uh
we have passed um the request along to
Chris Shea
um that uh lap State extensions
um I believe
um you must have realized by now it's
hard to get Consultants to finish jobs
on time let alone bid them and then
deliveries are just they keep getting
fed back I have projects that just
pulled the microphone a little closer to
you okay I have projects that
um we ordered a electric panel in August
of this last year and they're telling me
the delivery date is July 25th the
project was supposed to be up and
running for some summer classes and I
just deal with either that or rtus or or
just uh contractors not finding help I
would appreciate if we could get on page
nine the lap State extensions are listed
for nineteen dollars and 21 dollars
you know fy21 and so um
without it just bring that to your
attention that we would like those
extended to give me one more shot at
spending finishing the projects that I
have the the
um
budget
routing for us is we finish the project
first then we build a state for the
dollars it's not encumbered to us when
we have a contract up front so we're out
out there with contracts that extend
beyond the date so it puts me in a
little bit of a bind so appreciate that
okay anything further yes representative
Jack uh thank you if I could just
comment on the third one the policy of
the lapse team is to only remove
something if we are certain that the
contractors involved the project is
finished the contractors are all paid
uh and that's not the case on the third
one so we would definitely leave that in
all all three of those um the the third
one is actually two different critical
maintenance line items but they're
critical maintenance and uh so we'll be
actually
four different laws
that would apply to this I'm finishing
up like for instance the 17 I've I'll
have that gone the Littleton
um mobile diesel ATL advanced technology
lab that's the State dollars will be
expended by June 30th on that one so
there's some that I'm finishing up I'm
not carrying everything forward it's
just these
so
all right
um no further presentation
they um I just want to
make it known to you when I when I'm
when I'm looking for projects and what
priority there is no promise that
something's coming from this side but in
the event we're able to squeeze a rock
and we're able to find something we know
um what your priorities are and and we
will do our best
we appreciate that thank you very much
thank you
just about done here excuse me hey um
thank you Chris really appreciate being
able to pull all these departments
together for us uh there was mention
this morning by some of the members that
um of course we're not here next week
but the following week we come back in
Earnest we're here Monday and Friday
Friday was not in the budget or excuse
me it was not in the calendar
and I've come to find out that there was
a feeling that we may have a room
conflict but we don't so they'll they'll
put the rest of that in so you'll be
here Monday and Friday that week
and as I said before the beginning on
Friday and they tend to move quickly
um capital budget long range so we
should be able to start pretty close to
time
and on Friday the 10th we scheduled to
start at 10 30 to make sure we have
enough time for capital budget long
range to get done since it's all in this
room as well all right those two
meetings may take a little bit longer
just because it's your organization
meeting
um and then there'll be a few items on
each meeting right now capital budget
overview I think has
three two or three action items in Long
Range has I think up to four okay right
at the moment so today's the deadline
for agencies to get us stuff so we'll
start getting information next week on
that
um so the packets will go out next
Thursday or Friday okay and we'll go out
to the committee members so you'll see
what's going to be on the agenda for the
following Friday thank you
um in terms of what you're hearing today
and going forward so for instance
um you asked administrative services to
provide you with some information
additional information they'll come
through me typically and then I'll
forward that out to the committee so
you'll be getting emails from me uh
throughout the week as we get
information from agencies that were
requested
lastly at lunchtime I sent you all an
email and put a hard copy down to the
house bill to
potentially the house bill 2
Appropriations the the governor's
trailer Bill also in that email is a
second document that our office compiled
which just is the kind of a narrative of
what the sections of the governor's
trailer bill
are trying to accomplish so it's kind of
a high level summary
so just I just sent that to you as well
I didn't give you hard copies of that it
was an 18 page document and I think it's
read it as you're at your leisure
um so if there's anything anybody needs
in the next week before you see me uh
again feel free to reach out like I said
call email
um you'll get one more email from me
tonight just reminding you that the
documents from today's presentations are
loaded on our website and where to go
see it
thank you
all right so um that's uh that's we're
done for the day you have the week off
hopefully you have a chance to do
something as my mother always told me
just remember the end of the week you've
got to get rest before you come back to
go to school so
look forward seeing you the following
week thank you